Do Bond
and
am live.
Ooh.
Take a sip of that delicious coffee at
the best coffee.
So is that an advocate?
Me Fight.
Claw.
It sure is.
Just have it on here.
You guys have the same one as this
caveman coffee tastes going.
Who hooked me up with.
There you go.
Here you go.
We need to Redo those.
So did you hear?
There was some fights this weekend.
I mean I breezed by him.
I saw the highlights.
I thought you brought me on to talk
politics.
Let's trump get onto that.
Nobody.
Nobody's talking about politics these
days.
Thank God important thing.
We should bring it up because it's not
like I.
I went on a few celebrities,
twitter pages and I was like freaking
out.
Freaking out.
They won't shut the fuck up about it.
It's nonstop.
Nonstop.
And half of it is almost like,
I think like they want everyone to know
that they're upset.
They want everyone to know that they're
one of the upset people and they're,
they're not one of the make America
great again.
People they promote that they're upset.
Like I promote a live show.
I want people to know where they're at,
where they stand on it was this one
female comic.
I go to her page every now and then and
I just go Jesus Christ to.
I almost want to send a dm just like you
gotta chill out.
Just relax,
chill out.
We'll just see what is happening with
Amy Schumer.
Oh,
so anti trump.
But you can't,
you can't make it that,
that,
that part of the act like we were
putting in tickets and people just like
walking out,
but she keeps harping on it.
Well,
you know,
there's two ways to look at is one way
that people will say they have a voice
and if they have a voice it needs to
get,
you know,
they need to use that voice to get the
word out.
Not at a comedy show though.
Yeah.
I didn't mean to cut you.
Right,
but make me laugh.
Don't even call her a bitch.
She would call herself a bit.
You know what I'm saying?
This back in the day,
she would.
I mean,
she's like way more.
She's way more like political in
feminist now than ever before.
If you go back to the old amy Schumer
that was on,
like opie and Anthony,
she wasn't into that at all.
She was,
she was like one of the guys that was
like a selling point.
Maybe she was still May.
She got a little older and she was like,
man,
I want to talk about them and stuff,
but that's not the platform for it.
I don't write well if it is,
you got to be really funny.
Like if you have like an anti Donald
Trump joke,
that's fine.
For sure.
It's got to be funny.
It's got to be just like,
there's no room for that.
Like it used to be that comics could
have like these rants where they made
like really important points inside of
funding wouldn't be funny and people
kind of accepted it.
But that's what a podcast is for sure.
This a new world.
We live in a new world.
I go to a,
um,
an action movie.
I don't go to an action movie to get a
massage.
Now all of a sudden when you're in the
actual movie,
someone comes over and massage you,
relax.
Do you need to relax?
You need to be less tense because you're
really concerned about this action film.
It's really relevant.
It was like watching a porno.
I don't give a shit about the story I've
asked through.
You know what I'm saying?
I fast forward to the good stuff,
man.
It's like I need them.
Some people do like the story with the
story.
They want these people to be in love or
they want them to be escaping a bad
relationship and mommy issues.
I don't know.
I'm just saying there's a place in time
for it,
like do you see Dave Chappelle on
Saturday night live?
Funny time.
Made a good point.
Yes.
Yeah,
but he's also supportive is brilliant.
He a master.
He's a master.
He's the best.
He's also a very sincere person.
Like one of the things that is driving
me crazy about a lot of this tweeting
and craziness.
Like I was in New York City for the
fights and me and my friend campaigns.
We went to the gym and young Jamie was
there too,
but you weren't with us when we were
stuck in the.
In the swarm of humans with just me and
cam,
we've got to the gym,
no problem,
but on our way back,
the protest had marched through the area
that we walked through and all of a
sudden we couldn't go anywhere.
It was just jammed with people.
So you're literally shoulder to shoulder
with people like just everybody's
touching everybody.
There's just.
You had to deal with it.
There was nothing to do with,
which is one of the reasons why a fanny
pack is so important folks,
because you keep your money in your
front.
Okay?
Nobody's pickpocket and zipped up.
My shirt goes over.
That sentence is going to know to get
the.
It's going to take some work because
pickpockets do go to those things you
need to be aware of.
You're one of those super lefties.
It likes to go going down the street,
shit checked.
So while we're walking this one guy with
this perfectly manicured beard,
I'll never forget,
he had a really nice like wool jacket
on.
He was.
He was obviously like a wealthy liberal
character and he's screaming out.
I mean screaming in my fucking ear.
He's right here.
He's,
he's touching me.
He's touching me.
The shoulders.
Yeah.
Donald trump.
Racist,
sexist,
and he wouldn't stop.
He wouldn't stop partying.
And part of me wanting to go,
hey man,
could you just like if you want to go in
the protest,
the protests in the street,
like you're on the sidewalk.
This isn't the protest,
you know,
this isn't the answer because some
noncommittal shit you're doing like if
you want to be out in the be all in.
But he's like,
he's doing drive bys.
He's like a walk by screaming protests.
But does it really do anything?
He saw a black guy and that distance,
I swear to God,
he starts going shut up lives matter
black lives.
Hell No.
Hell,
that was so obvious.
Just trying to get everybody to join
them with my friend Michael Shermer
likes to call virtue signaling.
That's what it is.
He's peacocking his virtue and just
trying,
just trying to get everybody to jump on.
Growing up there was a woman with a sign
that said Rape Melania Cisa,
and apparently that's writing that thing
out.
Crazy.
Here we go.
It's a Hashtag on twitter.
Now,
here's what's crazy,
here's what's crazy.
Twitter allows that Hashtag twitter
doesn't allow Hillary for prison.
What?
Check that.
Make sure that's correct.
Biases that make sure that's correct
because that's what I've been reading.
Jamie,
will you Hashtag Hillary for prison?
Look if there's any tweets and then
Hashtag.
That's ridiculous.
Dude.
There's pictures of people with those
signs.
I don't think it's just one person and
there's a bunch of people used it who
call themselves like as if somehow or
another,
if Donald Trump is a misogynist,
somehow or another,
the way to get them back is to rape his
wife or even to suggest raping his wife.
What kind of messages are you spreading?
If you're posting that and you're in,
you're in a protest,
you're making a sign of that fucking
scary.
What does it say?
Hillary?
Hillary for prison.
I searched it.
There's a lot of stuff that pops up.
Okay.
Um,
well they might spend it in less than
maybe they abandoned before ms.no.
Maybe this guy doesn't know what he's
talking about and I just read some
nonsense.
Yeah.
Maybe I just read some nonsense.
Maybe I could've read some nonsense.
All of it is just bullshit.
It's just bullshit.
There was so many,
so many angry,
angry people and um,
well how many celebrities were like,
if trump wins,
I'm out of here.
You can't go.
No.
Where did you see the fucking signs that
people have made some artists made for,
you know,
those benches for bus station benches
where they have the billboard in the
back of it for real estate sales.
Yeah.
It's a real estate sale and it's all
these people who said they're going to
leave the country.
It's their face.
Like one of them is share.
That's awesome.
I think amy Schumer's got one of them
to.
Everyone says that you're not doing
shit.
You ain't going anywhere.
He said she was going to move to Spain,
but she's a fucking comedian.
You know?
It's just like,
I guess I'm learning Spanish.
That's just what a comedian would say.
See?
Know people freak out,
Matt.
But what she said is that like,
you know,
you're,
you're just as disgusting as the people
who voted.
That people will actually expect me to
move or just as disgusting as the people
who voted for that anti gay woman hater
or whatever,
whatever she called them,
but series of insults,
she just so upset and then obviously
she's performing.
She's doing theaters in stadiums,
even bigger arenas.
I mean,
she's killing it.
She's been to Kennedy Election Day sale.
Meanwhile,
here's what you need to understand.
If you do,
great.
By the way,
if you do wind up moving to Canada,
when you move to Canada,
you realize that Canada has a very
similar immigration policy to a Donald
Trump is proposing strict,
very strict.
It's incredibly difficult to immigrate
to Canada.
You don't just do it like that.
You don't just go over there and all of
a sudden you live there.
I mean maybe for Amy Schumer and you've
got some cash.
Maybe it's still straight.
People don't realize how strict it is.
Fucking strict.
I'm just going to go to Cayman.
No.
Yeah.
It's essentially very similar to a
Donald Trump is proposing.
Here's the thing about Canada and I love
Canada.
I'm a huge fan.
They're like some of my favorite people
in the world.
When you go to Canada,
if you have a drunk driving thing on
your record,
you can't get in.
They fucking send you home habits all
the time to deal with the UFC too with
American fighters.
If you have anything you the chance to
be getting up there,
getting cleared.
Customs as strict as shit.
Yeah.
Kevin James got into,
you know,
just a standard fistfight once when he
was younger and I believe he was,
I believe he was arrested but no charges
were filed and was all dropped.
It was one of those,
you know,
there's a brawl and he was a part of it
and he got arrested with a couple other
people.
No big deal.
You something a young guy did.
He lived here to fucking to just for
laughs and they flag them for it.
Turned them around.
Eddie Bravo went up there.
Eddie Bravo legally was carrying a gun
legally because he was.
No,
no,
no.
Listen to me.
He was working for a cash checking
business.
This is way back in the day before I
even met him,
and Eddie used to have to carry around a
large sums of cash and he had a license
to carry a pistol because of that,
so he gets pulled over for speeding or
something and he tells the cop.
He goes,
hey man,
just so you know,
I work for a check check cashing company
and I carry large sums of cash and I
have a pistol and it's loaded and it's
in the car,
and the guy goes,
okay,
we'll step out of the car.
Give me all your paperwork in this down.
I'm going to have to handcuff you while
we check this out.
So check it out.
They go,
Yep,
you're all good.
They let him go,
so nothing right,
no charges,
nothing.
Carrying a pistol illegally.
Every time he goes to Canada it comes
up.
Damn Dude,
he got so bad.
Then when would go to Canada,
I would ditch him.
I didn't want to get pulled in
emigration.
If I said it a know if I said I was with
him,
they pulled me in to integrate
immigration to the show.
Dude,
I got stuck there for a fucking hour and
a half ones.
They might not let his ass thing because
the conspiracies like we just can't
tower tower at our live shows because we
keep getting so do you not hate each
other?
How's it work?
Get out at it.
I love Eddie and then someone started a
literally a chant or seventh.
Just see that fucking meme with Tony
Ferguson when Tony Ferguson beat Hoffeld
dos Anjos.
Eddie Bravo was saying something.
It's like when your boy just winds his
fight,
but you have some new information about
tyler and he's like,
he's all open to whoever made that is
brilliant there to listen.
My brother,
anybody that thinks I don't love Eddie,
you're crazy.
Whatever nutty things that he believes
that I don't believe I don't give a
fuck.
I love that dude.
No.
Yeah,
I still love him too.
He's my friend.
He's just batshit crazy and in his kind
of way.
I still liked that flavor that he's
delivering toys.
That shit.
He's so into it.
He loves it.
He'll send me.
Was texting nonstop about it.
He sends us group texts.
You see the latest one is putting on
twitter about some of it's grainy
footage that looks like it was invented
back when the fucking wheel was
invented.
It's grainy footage of some guy talking
about the sex parties they used to have
with children whose to pro.
Hillary is not Satan.
You don't really think she's saying
that.
I don't man.
I kinda find it hard to believe in the
lash out at me.
I'm sorry.
I say tenant colts when you see shit
like eyes wide shut though.
Don't you want to know?
Can you hear about like the skull and
bones stuff these do at Yale?
Yeah.
That's just real.
Yeah,
like that is real.
So I would,
I would wonder like if you grow up in
the Hamptons or you live in a like one
of those crazy Connecticut towns where
all those super billionaire hedge fund
characters live and all their kids go to
the private schools that get sent to
these big fucking universities and you
get pledged to a fraternity because your
dad was in it and you know there's a lot
of that shit going on there called the
skulls right.
That's,
like I said,
was just the skulls.
No.
Well,
there probably might be a goal too.
Yeah,
maybe it isn't movie.
They would never invite us into that
stuff.
They just won't shut the fuck up.
Dot chatty.
Cathy's he tell them anything.
They just blasted on the show.
I can't have them on the.
We would never know.
There's no anybody that thinks we're
getting in on the Illuminati.
I get accused of that so much because of
the flat earth people,
the flat earth people believe I'm.
I'm a paid shill.
I know I get is.
Oh,
you're just going to leave the UFC and
step right into that.
You don't think that's the Illuminati
working?
You don't think he's part of it.
Rogan dragged him into it.
Yeah,
man.
You don't think I would chat away on my
show about.
It would be a hilarious is if there
really was sort of organization that was
paying people off to lie about the earth
being flat,
that would be amazing.
If like we were able to keep it that
hush hush.
If the world was flat this whole time
and all these people that claim to be
flying around it in a big circle,
like people have navigated the globe in
a plane,
they flying,
flown over it in a plane and they were
all in on it.
They're all good just to.
Everyone's in.
I go over their house,
Ferrari,
tesco,
everybody's partying like,
what'd you get out of this money?
Shut the fuck up,
dude.
Shut up.
Just from just from a boat going around
the world.
Yeah,
man.
It's all flat.
Earth money.
Flatter,
denial.
Money.
Huge.
This is a.
This is the world that he probably lives
in.
He hasn't quite gone flat.
Earth.
Flat.
Earth pulls them back.
They start messing with it a little bit.
He did.
He did,
but he went.
Dinosaurs aren't real.
Dinosaurs aren't real,
and the in the moon is fake.
We've never been to the moon.
Well,
not only that,
all the footage of NASA are all the NASA
footage is fake.
NASA.
Everything was shit and then the,
the bands,
all the bands like the Beatles were made
by the CIA and quite apparent to paying
your claims.
The thing is though,
if you know Eddie and he's a fun dude
and half of this stuff is because he
enjoys it.
He enjoys looking at conspiracies just
like.
And it looks.
Some of them are true,
right?
There's real.
That's the problem.
That's the real problem.
The real,
some are true.
So he has an argument on some stuff,
but it's hard for keys.
So balls deep into conspiracies that
it's hard for him to just like deep that
he's bent over like a clothes pin and
his,
his like his ankles are in.
Yeah.
He's like,
what is this?
That's a nice tower.
Be Ashamed as someone knocked it down
was just recently.
He just posted probably listening to us.
He's so funny.
He's so crazy.
But the thing too,
he's passionate about it so people think
when him and I discuss it or discuss it,
you know,
and he's so passionate.
He's not arguing with.
He's just like tick,
like if you really think something's
true,
you're like,
come on man,
that's,
that's Eddie.
Well here's my take on a lot of this
shit.
There's not that much time.
You don't have much time.
You have 24 hours in a day and you got
to sleep for eight,
so that's not a lot of time for me and
if I go down these goddamn fucking
rabbit holes,
that shit will take forever.
Have done it with.
I've done it with legitimate things.
I've done it with a,
you know,
like archeological fucking discoveries
were all just start reading up on some
crazy temple that they found in Cambodia
and I'm two and a half hours later I'm
researching this and I'm like,
God,
I got to,
I got shit to do.
So like for me to do that about ghosts,
the facing what some of these conspiracy
theories on her list,
you just don't have.
So just the.
I mean,
what am I going to do?
What are we going to find?
Someone,
the Internet,
no one else has found what I'm saying.
Like I'm fucking Nicolas Cage from
national treasure.
Like I'm not going to go on this weird
escapade planning some.
No one else knows and I can just ask the
Eddie because he,
he is a.
yeah,
but he'll fucking double black belt.
And conspiracy theories makes you watch
youtube videos.
So he tried to get us during the last
fight companion.
He tried to put one on two to 25
minutes,
five minutes to her.
A lifelock.
It,
I can't do it.
I don't have it in me.
I don't have an inmate.
I forget what that one was about.
Something about money or something or
tower.
So he loves him.
He loves does to sport to him.
But you know,
it's what he's into.
Yeah.
I don't have time anymore to people.
Oh,
you fucking Solo.
No Bro.
Fuck no,
no,
no.
If you solve the Kennedy assassination,
it will not help your life.
But it's also not on the Internet.
Hey,
tell you that it's probably not in some
chat room you're in.
It might be on youtube.
Just kind of find the video.
You just got to go down deep enough.
You're going to about 600 views so far.
But if we can get it out there,
someone sent me a fucking three hour one
just two days ago.
Well to assassination one.
I'm like,
I don't,
I can't simply too long.
You can do it anymore,
can't do it,
and if they do figure it out it would be
interesting,
but I don't.
I don't see how they could.
I think they're never going to get past
where they're at right now.
There's some evidence.
There's some non evidence.
There's some speculation.
There's some,
there's that Zapruder footage,
there's some shit.
But is there any expert like actually
opened the case back up?
Like did they really give a shit?
There's not enough evidence right now.
Like current physical evidence.
It's not happening.
It's over.
Yeah.
They wouldn't do it anyway because who
are you going to try?
But also everyone gets a shit.
He's Dad.
Yeah,
everyone's dead.
What are you going to do?
Yeah.
What are you gonna do.
Alright.
Still isn't bringing back.
It's all so fucking weird.
Like because we know the government does
a bunch of fucked up things.
We know they do,
but it's,
it's spending time trying to figure it
out.
That's what I was thinking when I saw
trump sit next to Obama.
I wonder if Obama told him how much work
has to actually do and that's why he
lived so fucked up because trump was
sitting next to obama and it was just.
He looked like Jesus Christ.
He looked like he was like,
what?
I think it hit it.
Hit them.
During that meeting I was like,
this is my daily life.
Here you go,
and he's like,
holy look at it is what it says.
Trump reportedly surprised at scope of
new presidential doozies.
Surprised at scope.
God's various.
Well,
it's like you have 100 jobs.
This is a reason why the age so hard.
It shouldn't be one man.
Shannon be responsible for it.
I think you've spoken about it before.
We'd have one guy with that much power
and to have all that on his pressure
should be a committee of just straight
geniuses that figuring it out.
Well man,
if you want to look at the bright cloud,
if there's any bright cloud about Donald
Trump being in office,
is that he doesn't.
He's an outsider,
like complete outsiders,
politics guy and so we'll get to see
just by watching them sort of duke it
out,
what shape they take,
you know,
we'll get to see like what,
what,
what's,
what's.
We'll get a better view of the mechanism
behind the machine.
Then if Hillary Clinton was in office,
don't you think with.
I think people are really surprised at
how little power he's actually.
The president actually has probably
because they think he's going to do all
this crazy stuff and then p room like,
Nah,
bitch don't work like that.
You have jumped through all these holes.
The house of Lake state,
all this stuff.
Yeah.
Well that's what's going to be
interesting to hear him talk and
complain about that and see what happens
and it's going to be interesting.
We've got a culture battle going on
right now to like all those people
marched down the street screaming.
Not My president,
not my president,
and he is.
He is though.
I hate to tell you guys.
He is.
Well,
he's the,
you know,
you don't like get the president doesn't
become yours so it's not yours.
If you live in the United States though,
he's the president of United States.
You look at me.
Did you say my president,
my president?
I do.
You do?
Not My president trump.
They'll president.
Yeah.
He's not president,
not my president.
And there's a whole new world of my own.
It is weird.
Yeah.
What?
I don't know.
It's probably.
Look,
I think this is what I've been saying,
that we go like this and we go like
that.
We go right and we go left and this is
how people always have.
When they go back and forth,
the country goes back and forth.
We tried one way.
We don't like it.
They said he was supposed to be at UFC
200.
Five was son was there.
Which one?
Donald trump jr got.
They're not gonna win any awards for
good luck or they got a bad looking guy
really well with the youngest,
youngest one or the one who's like
killing it.
There's one is the one who's got the
hair slicked back.
Darker hair.
I'd have to see him.
He's a nice dude.
It was he cool.
He's,
I've,
I've been.
Actually I knew him from a while ago.
He's friends with a friend of mine.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So the family is going to have to take
over his other business adventures while
he's president.
How about that whole thing is so crazy,
so weird.
So crazy.
Looking him at him up there.
It's so crazy.
How many of them are going to live in
the White House?
Do they know?
I don't know.
Didn't win?
Yeah.
I could.
All of them live they want.
Or is there like a cap?
Like,
dude,
you can only bring to you.
Can't be up in there.
Do you know who I fucking love?
Who is that sheriff?
That black sheriff that wears a cowboy
hat everywhere.
Sheriff?
Uh,
the gut houses.
Goddamn name.
The one out of Dallas.
I think he is.
We're swimming at the same dude.
He's The Dallas shooting happened.
Always?
Yes.
Something.
Clark is his name.
Clark.
He's.
He retired.
Did he?
Well,
he recently retired from like Fox News.
Dude's always on.
I want to follow the same guy.
Maybe here I'll find them because I just
started Eric Holder.
What is it?
David Clark,
[inaudible] name's David Clark,
Bro.
Sheriff David Clarke.
Eric holder's,
the attorney general.
You fuck you.
Not American and American.
How do you not know that?
You don't know who eric holder's.
How dare you like to do that when I know
someone or other people don't know how
the fuck do you not know that,
bro?
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a fucking character.
That guy.
He wears a cowboy hat in honor of his.
What is his family members?
A Dallas Cowboy.
So he wears a Dallas Cowboy.
Had everywhere,
right?
He wears the hat.
Actual cowboy hat.
That's everywhere else,
sir.
Um,
there's a crazy picture that he posted
of Donald Trump winning the ellis
island.
A world award in 1989 standing next to
Muhammad Ali and Rosa parks.
Damn.
I was award for contributing to the
conditions of inner city inner city
black youth standing alongside Muhammad
Ali and Rosa part.
I want to talk about that.
Yeah.
Well,
it doesn't help.
Trump is like,
the head of KK was like,
we got,
we,
we basically got them in there like we
support them.
We're the ones that were.
The reason you got in there,
he had to come out and be like,
I don't,
I'm not cool with that KKK stuff,
man.
Like that's not me.
Kay Kay Kay,
racist,
sexist.
It's kind of catchy though.
I wanted to tell him man,
go out into the street.
But I was worried.
I was literally worried in the street.
If I said it,
it'd be like,
you fucking racist.
What did you like trump supporter?
Like he was.
His vitriol was.
And then they're all up on you and the
be like Joe Rogan.
No,
I said,
just go to the.
Come on man,
go over there.
Get over there man.
He's actually protesting.
Don't make me get campaigns.
Get his fucking bone out and start
fucking working people and be able to
draw back.
There was no room to draw.
It was just,
it was so crazy how many people were
there.
It was just strange just to protest
thousands of people.
You're busy as it is,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
you know,
the cops broke it up like cops were
screaming and shit.
So it was like that being there at the
weekends with the biggest fights in
history,
all of it was just so crazy.
It was a.
That was a nutty scene,
man.
Being there and the fans felt surreal.
It felt friendly.
It's.
It happened.
Yeah.
It was like.
It was crazy.
Like the weight of the event was thick
in the air.
It had this feel to it.
That was very different than any other
show we'd ever put together.
It shows that that was the one show.
I wish I was that because it was so
special.
It's gonna be tough to beat that,
but it'll never be.
I mean you'll have big giant events for
sure,
but it'll never be like that because
that was the last block.
Yes.
Corruption.
Correct.
That was standing in front of the UFC,
getting into New York.
I got a little worried when I saw where
it was.
I think when I was in Atlanta doing
latrobe,
I saul on the,
on twitter,
like the crazy press conference with
connor doing that stuff.
I'm like,
I'm not.
And it was kind of weird.
I was like,
well,
it seems a little gimmicky,
blah,
and then the way,
and he looked a little more serious and
then the night of the fight.
So I was like,
I mean,
you couldn't have written a better show.
the,
the fight that night,
the way everything happened,
it was amazing.
Man.
By far,
the best ufc I've ever seen.
It was by far the main event was almost.
It was almost bizarre.
It's almost bizarre how good.
Connor.
It's almost bizarre the way you picked
apart Eddie Alverez.
Almost bizarre.
Like magical.
That's almost the word I wanna use.
Correct.
Like he touches motherfuckers with that
left hand.
Have you ever seen Eddie Alvarez just
like they'd even look like they were in
the same planet.
Like one guy like looked like he was
from Mars.
The other guy look like he's just a
normal dude trying to figure it out.
Well,
it looked like Eddie.
The moment he got hit with like,
what the fuck we could see on his face.
He was like,
holy Jesus,
what am I doing here?
And then he goes,
well,
all right.
He's not very good at wrestle.
Let me try this.
Wrestling coach like that was your shot.
Oh Bro.
You're in for a long night.
I think that he realized like,
Holy Fuck,
boys are already touched up a little bit
when he finally went in for the shot,
you know,
and I just think I'm connor new.
Then also that he had them and how calm
was he?
Ridiculous.
Just come upright and just waiting.
And then the accuracy of that Combo that
finally finished Eddie.
That's what I think makes connor so
specials is accuracy.
When he throws punches,
Eddie's moving as he's laying in this
stuff.
I've never seen anything like,
like you said,
it was straight up magical and like,
all right,
well we've never seen a guy like this.
We just haven't.
I don't know if we ever.
Well either.
It was really interesting too when I was
interviewing him and it's like you've
got to have some attributes if you want
to beat me,
you got to be tall,
you've got to be big.
It can be these guys my size to what
he's doing though it.
So he's a once in a lifetime guy because
he sent in the ceiling,
like there's no,
there's no boundaries for him.
Like he's just like,
I'll fight nate at 70,
I'll,
I'll 45 sure on merch Aldo in 13 seconds
and they'll come to 55.
Like we've never seen this kind of
creativity.
And we've also never seen the UFC allow
someone to do this either.
Yeah.
Well he's just such a unique
personality.
It's undeniable,
but also his style in a lot of ways.
It kind of does a lot of,
like with wonderboy does,
but with less kicks,
like he throws kicks to the body.
I'll throw like some front kicks.
I mean,
you know,
like maybe 70 percent as many kicks.
Wonderboy is a little more kick heavy,
but it's that sideway style and he's.
But he,
uh,
he,
I think he does it better.
Like there's maybe something about the
focus of the shots that he's landing,
the precision of them because wonderboy
very rarely like touches somebody up
like that with a punch.
He just doesn't have that kind of power.
Yeah,
you're right.
I think wonder is better at surprising
guys with this kicks in his angles,
but connor set it up and he's landing
combos that are all so precise in this
power,
like he's touching dudes and you can see
it on their faith.
He touched Eddie and Eddie's like,
what stuff?
Well,
not only that,
he's like he's hitting them in a
surprise way and it's not telegraphing
it at all.
Like his ability to like go from
bouncing around to launching that shot
is so quick.
It's so.
It's so precise and it's so focused and
there's no fat in his movements.
It's just.
Yeah,
and they said there's going to be a big
announcement afterwards and off these
girls pregnant,
which I mean it's a personal big
announcement for him,
but I think he said he's going to take
time off and he wants a piece of the
Pie.
He wants a piece of wme and what,
you know,
what they're doing now,
which,
which is hilarious.
Right.
I love it.
Me Too.
And he's the first fighter ever that can
talk like this.
How old is.
He was kind of 26,
maybe 27,
26,
got to think 28.
I think he's a smart guy too.
I don't.
I mean I would hope at least I don't see
him fighting deep into his thirties
know.
Especially the way he talked to.
He goes,
now that I have a kid,
I know what I bring to the table.
I won't be set financially for the rest
of my life.
You guys want me to fight again?
Yeah,
I'm leaving.
You need to be set for the rest of my
life.
I want to.
I want a part of this pie and he's his
next fight and it's gonna be such a
fight is with wme.
It's not with anyone out there.
If you.
If you think he's fighting for center,
it could be your batshit crazy.
That's not happening for a very long
time.
Maybe.
Maybe they work it out and I don't think
so.
I think the next slide again,
I don't know.
That's just me going off.
Whatever the hell I think Joe,
but I think his next fight would be nate
for the belt at 55 because if you think
it could be even Tony,
they're both deserving and we're mma.
Pierce were balls deep in mma.
We love it and one of those guys
deserves it.
As far as numbers and in in a big pay
per view,
it would have to be native to really
think they would do nate again,
100 percent.
I don't think Nader economy will fight
unless it's.
If it's.
If that has to be the matchup.
I think connor will fight someone out.
I think connor might even fight Woodley
you.
I think you'd see a fight with Woodley
before you see qbb.
Ferguson I think could be the first one.
Will fight each other before anything
else.
You know?
Fucking crazy.
It would be if he decided to go up and
fight Woodley.
It's so not.
Obviously Willie has to get through
wonderboy again,
but does he has,
do you think so?
We'll.
We'll say.
Dana said that's the.
That's the same thing.
A lot of shit he says is fighting for
the title.
It's good point.
It was like,
Nah,
let me see if I have a title.
Nah.
Yeah,
he does that all the time.
I don't think that means anything.
Thanks.
Good point.
I'm just going based off what your boys
said.
He was like,
that's the next rematch,
but put it on me more your friend than
mine.
Your real.
You've worked with him forever.
I liked the guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I liked Dana.
I just think you know you have a closer
relationship so say you're a boy,
but he does say things impulse back if
woodland that's there.
This other thing I worry about though,
not.
You don't have to worry about something
to think about.
How much power are they going to give
connor?
40th five.
50 five slash 70 just wraps up all the
dude.
You know.
Crazy.
That would be if he did it though,
I say let them do it.
Let them try.
Use is gone.
We can't.
He's got to take this pitching woodley.
We'll say.
Let him try.
Fuck outwardly a say.
Try whether it would love that you
don't.
Big Woodley looks compared to him.
Ju Ju,
Ju Ju ginormous.
It's so bizarre.
Looking at Woodley inside the octagon.
You know what?
He's the most Jack Dude,
I think other than your.
Well Romero.
He's in there.
Other one and two.
One and two right now.
Interchangeable,
yeah.
Yeah.
It depends what you're into,
but you're well flies through the air.
You'll weld.
Does backflips at the beginning of every
fight at the beginning of your friend.
He goes into the audience or it goes
into the cage and he does backhand
springs and literally launches himself
through the air and lands on his feet.
It's the Olympics and it's a solid
landing and he's 200 pounds.
Correct.
So.
And he's flying.
Flying.
He's the freakiest freak.
Cascade uses.
Yes.
Yeah.
Jesus.
My goal being you do that for me.
Somebody needs to help him with this
marketing.
Change a word,
but he lost so much.
He lost so much fan support.
When he said a four,
four was he say for the gay?
Gee,
we thought he said gay Jesus.
But he said,
don't forget Jesus is broken.
English was so bad.
People went bad on them so fast they did
and then he kept calling bisbing boy.
Yeah.
Well it's okay because I like that he's
allowed.
If bisbing did that to him,
we had some shit on her hands.
I cannot say that to a man of color.
Oh he does.
He's so scary.
Poor Weidman in New York.
Hometown needed to win bad.
The only getting no love in New York and
then just a fucking knee from Cuba just
don't,
just flew,
flew through the air and as he hit him,
like he was flying over them afterwards.
But,
but you know,
that was insanely impressive,
it was almost as impressive as the way
he took waibans back.
He tripped him.
He's,
they tied up together.
He trips.
Weidman throws him to the ground and
then spins around behind him and takes
his back like the trip.
How about the world class trip trip?
No,
that's world class level trip.
Weidman's an absolute monster and he was
just throwing them around,
showing them the difference between a
wrestler from the Olympics.
A guy who medaled in every single world
tournament he entered and
built like a Ninja Turtle.
He's ridiculous.
And you know,
he has like a fuse disc in his neck.
I would assume he had a serious injury
in his neck just like Weidman has.
But why may that disectomy Wyman?
That surgery?
He did.
So ul has a big scar in the back of his
neck.
You could see it.
It's like a big slice.
It's all stitched up like ving rhames
from pulp fiction.
Very different.
But you know what I'm saying?
The same scar.
Black Guy Lights.
Yeah.
It's um,
you know,
I've seen it before on other guys,
but spinal surgeries,
fucking no joke,
man.
I had,
I had Weidman when that fight till then
he won the first round.
But you thought he wanted the second
round when yoga was throwing them
around?
Uh,
no.
Not winning,
but I thought as the fight would go on,
it would help Weidman.
I thought in the second round you well
started implementing his wrestling and I
thought he was running away with it.
And then.
So one one,
right?
Yes.
I thought it was one,
one,
one one,
but I thought it was like shocking how
good his wrestling was in comparison and
we know that doesn't mean he doesn't
show it very,
very rarely,
but when he does,
dudes go flying more because he's having
fun,
having a good time to.
For Real.
At first when he was talking stuff that
busy,
I'm like,
God,
that's a terrible fight for bisping.
that's terrible.
And then it hit me like five rounds.
Bisbing really doesn't initiate in that
grappling and he has cardio four days.
That's a tough fight to call.
At first I'll they get Romeo is going to
fucking destroy business.
Not really though.
If you think about it.
Not really.
Who knows what could happen,
but Dan Henderson caught bisping twice
bad in their last title fight at 45
years old or whatever it is to catch him
really bad.
And Dan Henderson,
who is one of the most ruthless power
strikers in the game for sure,
and bisping survived that,
so that's good for bisping was able to
survive that.
You know,
it'd be good to think Yoel Romero
doesn't just have a right hand.
He flies.
He literally launches himself at you.
If he gets a hold of you,
you,
the wrestling coach.
Dan Henderson's a silver medalist in the
Olympics as well.
But it's a different.
It's different.
Different.
Yeah.
Especially Dan right now.
What's Dan Forty eight?
I think he's 46 or 45.
He's up there either way,
but broome is basically,
you know,
in his prime as an MMA fighter.
Well also there's like the range of
motion,
like Dan's almost like locked up.
Some would say stiff.
Yeah,
he's got.
But if he hits you,
you're Foxville.
But he's like,
his range of motion is very limited.
Whereas well is like a super athlete.
He doesn't have any limitations in his
range of motion.
He's ridiculously flexible.
Like he does like a half split before
he,
um,
for a fight he was like down there,
like stretching out your like sky's
range of motions and saying those knees
in the flying knees though,
a lot of it,
especially with Weidman came from
Weidman going for that single leg and
he's like,
go,
go for it again.
See what happens.
Yeah.
And were busying doesn't entertain the
grappling at all.
That's true.
And he stays on the outside and he also
has that beast of a coach.
But at first right away I was like,
Oh God,
that sucks because I love Bisbee like
God,
that's a bad fight for him.
I was sitting there like,
well,
cardio five rounds if he can survive
those first two,
maybe three dragon lake water.
It's a fun fight to watch that bad,
bad boy.
I mean you can't.
It's hard to do mma.
Math,
right?
I'm mad man.
Style style matchups though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I was saying like bisping last,
Tim Kennedy,
Tim Kennedy last url,
but Tim Kennedy was beating your.
Well,
like that's another thing that you
always corner did this,
that it was fucked up man.
They covered him with water.
They threw water on him while he's
sitting there resting between first
second,
they put an ice pack on him and they,
he poured water on himself.
He put her on his legs,
he poured it on his arms,
he poured it all over them and they
wiped him down.
I mean he was trying to cool himself off
probably,
but you're not allowed to do that.
And they spent time wiping him down
before the round started.
So like they wiped him down in between
the corner,
but then the referee stopped it and made
them wipe them down more because more so
it gets more rest.
Yeah,
look for sure.
They are aware when,
when that happened with Tim Kennedy,
when Tim Kennedy had fucked up at the
end of that second round,
he absolutely,
and on-purpose stayed on that stool long
and then he was,
some would say it was a smart move.
Obviously it ended up working in his
faith.
Smart.
If you're a cheater,
if you're okay with cheating,
but it is cheating,
that's cheating.
You haven't a lot of percentage
cheating.
One hundred percent in that fight and
the referee should have probably stopped
the fight,
but I'm sure big John didn't want the
fight to end it.
Didn't want to cheat everybody out of
the fight and just wanting to get back
up.
But then you cheat.
Tim Kennedy who has done one person.
You don't want to cheat out of this
champ.
Tim is walking around like yelling while
this is all going off piste.
Yeah,
the whole thing was a mess.
It was a mess.
That was a cluster fuck of a moment,
but it just shows you.
This guy has a massive amount of
experience in international competition
in wrestling and there's like a lot of
shit that goes on and wrestling.
You know where your.
You have to take advantage of whatever
you can to win the all these years of
high level competition on the
international scene.
He's probably got a bunch of little
tricks like that he could do to slow
down the pace or give himself a little
extra time and,
and we and what people.
Oh,
what,
what's 15,
20 seconds?
15,
20 seconds for a guy like Yoel Romero to
replenish giant it.
I mean,
you're talking giant night and day
difference for a guy like that.
And I think it was also a 30 seconds for
the Tim Kennedy fight.
If I remember maybe 23.
I felt like it was longer than that.
I don't remember talking about stool
gait.
Yeah,
Gait.
Um,
but also then there's a psychological
issue because Kennedy now thinks the
fights over.
Is it not over?
Like he doesn't know where he's at.
There's nothing worse than that when you
think the fight's over and like,
oh,
back in man,
that's what kills me about glory when
they have that extra round.
Here we go one more round.
Imagine you get through three rounds of
kickboxing and then finally you're
drinking water.
You got your arms up her for her.
He says blah,
blah,
blah.
And it's draw.
What will think if you're tyrone Woodley
Woodley?
Well,
how about Bruce?
Buffer.
Fucking it up.
Where what was going on that decision
was because you were like,
Whoa,
everyone chill,
chill.
Well,
here's what was going on.
First of all,
Bruce said it wrong.
He was not a majority decision.
It was a majority draw.
Correct.
But they probably wrote it down wrong
for them.
The New York does not do any MMA.
They've never done that in May before
the first event.
Never shod shot.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
so they do this thing where they tally
up the scorecards,
they give it to bruce and I guess it
said majority decision.
Tyron Woodley,
they read to judges quarter to draw one.
Judge scores it for Woodley and Woodley
retains the title,
but it's supposed to be majority draw.
Yes.
That's what the majority of the people
thought it was a draw.
So it's a majority draw.
So Bruce said it wrong whether they gave
it to them wrong,
I don't know.
And Real Steve Harvey moment.
Yes.
And then they and then tire and freaked
out.
And then the audience booed.
The audience went crazy and I said,
do you still have your title?
Just hold.
And I was,
and they wanted bruce to say it again.
So Bruce says it again.
I was going to say it again onto the
microphone,
but they're like,
insisted he get the mic and he says it
again.
So he says it again and he.
Because he wanted to correct the
mistake.
So he says it again and then I have to
say that the audience is booing.
I'm like,
this is the exact same score.
Yes,
it's the exact same score.
It's just a wrong definition.
Just read,
run yet.
That's all.
And I think it was probably pretty
accurate too.
I think it was right before it.
I think maybe with 10 seconds left,
I look at Brian and I went,
I bet you anything.
It's crazy.
And I even tweeted out before this,
I think it's a draw triangles,
no championship math.
I go,
I feel like it's a draw I give.
I give that a 10,
eight and then I scored the other
rounds.
I forget what scoring.
I think it's a draw.
Some people didn't give Woodley eight
for the fourth insane because at the end
of the round wondered where it was on
top of him punching him.
That's insane.
Yeah,
but I say bully beat death,
anything.
If he didn't do that,
if,
if I'm wonder wonderboy didn't get out
and wasn't on top,
it might be at 10,
seven,
because not only did he hurt him with
big punches then he almost choked the
life out of them.
I mean he had them in a deep getting and
people were telling me that wasn't a
good team.
Like out of your fucking mind.
You're insane.
Have a guy,
a guy as strong as Woodley May.
Let's say his position is a little off
to the side.
Just for the record.
And what round is it?
Lauren?
Was that third round?
Third round.
So your cardio running fourth round.
Fourth Round.
You already exhausted and you have that
hundred 70 pound monster around your
neck.
He's not one 70 now.
He's every bit of what?
Pr?
200.
Probably 200 pounds.
And by the way,
he's a brown belt.
He's a brown belt in Jujitsu.
You think tyron woodley does not a choke
people.
You're fucking crazy.
It was a very good choke and I.
I was amazed.
He too.
Men,
I think I was thinking was like
wonderful as that skinny ass net and
tiny head,
smaller head than me and a small head
things that woody said.
Woody said,
well,
I knew he had a little head did.
He was like,
Oh shit.
I didn't even think about his head.
I was about the size of his neck.
He has a slender neck yet tiny head.
Isn't it amazing?
The human body can take that like nodded
his head and not rip off his neck.
Not Break.
That's what I'm saying.
We'll leave broken neck.
I guarantee you if you had that in the
first round,
he probably would have been able to.
I agree,
but how tough is it?
Well,
yeah,
I see what you're saying.
It have been a different story.
How tough is wonderboy though?
Ridiculous and I've,
and this is an I know wonderboy st
manager.
We've trained together.
Bunch love the guy.
I've always,
and this is just me,
I've always questioned his toughness
because he does come from a privileged
family,
like they have this huge Taekwondo
Academy,
South Carolina,
and he has a great home life and his
dad's,
his coach and his brothers are studs
Quando or just karate.
I'm not sure.
Just karate.
Karate style.
Yeah,
you're probably right.
One of those.
So.
But he had this huge school,
you know what I'm saying?
Very successful.
Been to dinners with his dad and the
whole family.
God,
this guy has everything going for him.
So when I see that's like,
you know,
it's the Calabasas kids thing,
like you've never seen the tufts can
tell bass isn't gonna do shit in the
UFC.
It's just that when they're privileged
like that.
So when the going gets rough,
I've always kind of questioned wonderboy
and I've never seen it though because
the Matt Brown fight,
you know,
his last loss and it was back and forth.
There's a scrap.
I'm like,
all right,
whatever this fight man.
I was,
I was watching with fans.
I was standing up clapping like,
what is going on right now?
Man,
what the fuck you talking about?
It was crazy fight and uh,
there's a lot interesting.
First of all,
how fucking hard is Tyron Woodley head?
Jesus Christ God who he has one of the
best trait,
right?
Hands in the business and fit lands.
I can't believe one avoiding getting
knocked out.
Unbelievable.
Well,
I mean he's a guy who fought and
professional kickboxing.
He has a 57 and oh,
combined kickbox and record amateur and
pro.
I guarantee he didn't fight anyone that
kickbox and circled that punches his
hardest and not with four ounce gloves.
Yeah,
exactly.
The other big,
he can punch faster with those little
gloves on and it hurts more wetlands.
So let.
So let's say Dana does do the rematch.
They don't do conor Woodley and they do
do the rematch.
I was thinking about it.
Three titles,
three titles,
but focus me third.
But a woodley was a slight underdog.
And if you listen to Duke Roufus who was
talking about their game plan,
you,
I think you're starting on the post
fight press conference.
Third Game Plan.
Why?
And you even mentioned it.
You're like,
I don't get why tyrone is against the
cage and I didn't like it either.
I'm like,
what's he doing?
He's get murdered.
That was their game plan because what do
you know?
He does that a lot.
Yes,
he does that a lot.
And then wonder boys a counter striker.
So they wanted to bring him to Woodley.
That was their thinking by him being
against the cage and do all that and
then get him to commit to take them
down.
So they kind of,
it surprised wonderboy a little bit,
but in the rematch I think it favors
wonderboy so much more because now he
knows Woodley's going to fight like
that.
He might not fight like that.
You might not find like that.
So then he.
So,
and this is my thing here.
I think the ability to change and,
and,
and be more dynamic in wonder boys
favorite his,
you know what I'm saying
in a way.
But here's the thing.
Woodley only took him down once in the
whole fight and mauled him.
Once he got onto the ground,
which is avoiding tee off,
what if one would,
if Woodley decides to do that every
fucking round,
you know,
I don't know how much wonderboy can stop
woodley from taking them down.
Woodley so much bigger,
so much stronger in a way better
wrestler.
Woodley takes him down like he took him
down to the first round.
I mean that might've been the strategic
error because Woodley mauled him in the
first round.
By the end of the round,
his nose is fucked up.
He's got a giant caught.
He's leaking blood and Woodley just held
him down and dominated him on the
ground.
So if he just does that in the round two
and I mean if he was able to do that
instead of trying to stay and knock him
out,
he might've been able to stop him.
Correct.
But the reason why he got that takedown
is based off those kicks.
And then one boy stopped kicking as like
he wasn't looking for the knockout.
Does that make sense?
Like he was so hesitant after that.
So.
And I feel like the reason he got that
was it because of the kick.
So I think wonderboy can make changes
more of changes to win the next flight.
Maybe who knows,
but I'm saying as far as game plan wise,
I think it favors wonderboy.
Yeah.
But here's the thing,
now that tyron knows like wonder boys
timing and he's be able to rock them.
He's gonna have some serious confidence
in launching that right hand.
But go ahead and move forward on one
voice.
See what happens.
Yeah.
But sometimes it works.
I mean he's been able to take them down.
Other people being able to take them
down and when he gets them down,
like the difference in the grappling was
pretty fucking evident to me look like a
white belt versus you know,
just so much stronger.
It's so much better at holding them in
place.
I was like,
man,
if this fight goes this way,
Woodley's going to run away with.
It was what I thought I thought to me,
to me,
busted them open.
Bad,
bad man.
And then when you're dealing with
wonderboy,
you're dealing with that weird sideways
stance.
And just popping that jab and his face,
hands down,
hands down.
He's a weird guy to spar with.
The other thing is one boy,
he didn't let his hands go at all at
all.
That lefthand and like,
he's so good going south.
Paul traditionally can go back and
forth,
but it was all kicks for him.
Well he,
I think he was worried after that
takedown and getting busted up,
have,
you know,
opening up,
getting taken down again.
But you know,
tyron is a totally different animal to
is a different animal than Johnny
Hendricks.
Like great.
Johnny.
Yeah.
And the Johnny Hendricks that wonderboy
faced.
Let's be honest,
he's not the same guy.
Not even close.
He just not know.
I don't know.
He's not the same guy that knocked out
John Fitch.
Martin Kampmann.
He's just not the same guy.
No,
just not know for whatever reason.
Speculate all you want Internet for
whatever reason.
I mean maybe it's motivation.
Maybe it's a personal problem.
Camps,
who knows?
He opened up a steak restaurant and it
went out of business.
Terrible idea.
But maybe he just terrible idea.
So to worst of your celebrity,
you've got some cash.
Maybe the worst idea of restaurants.
Not The way to gay.
I'm trying to be successful and happy.
I'd rather be stressed out,
broke.
I hate money.
Do you have a restaurant I can invest
in?
That's,
I mean,
it's a terrible idea.
Even if they just put his name on it,
he's still associated with that failure.
I'm sure he had to have some form of
commitment to it.
I'm sure you got a sign.
Will people even fucking t-bones for 30
percent off or something like that?
The uh,
the not read it.
Um,
the uh,
Yahoo and yelp reviews rather they were
terribly bad.
Other were the worst.
It was like one star.
We can be associated with that.
Like if you want to open up a restaurant
and you're a celebrity,
good luck.
And she'd be a really small place or ubs
or it'd be a silent investor.
Like don't be,
don't be the face of it.
Well,
there's a bunch of places like that in
La.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
Travis Barker.
Humans,
a crossroads.
You don't see a mark and stuff like
that,
but it's like an obviously not your cup
of tea,
but all a Vegan restaurant though.
It's like the number one place in La as
far as Vegan killing it.
Yeah,
but you don't see him blasting out there
like his face on the front of the
restaurant rather than playing the drums
while they're serving up spring rolls.
Well,
they were calling it the big rig
steakhouse.
God dammit.
Let some Texas Shit.
Yeah,
it's texts.
It might work in Texas.
Right.
Big Rig statement if it was on from big
rig,
whatever.
It was.
Awesome.
It sounds like though,
is it st?
No,
it doesn't.
Has that ever worked?
Well,
I guess you know elway did it.
John Wayne did his elway's steakhouse in
Denver.
Kills that real defined stake.
Ted Ted has them.
Who's Ted?
Ted Turner.
Oh,
he's got those texts.
Yeah,
true.
Shanahan's has meat and shit.
Yeah,
it's a tough Gig,
man.
Tough.
Rocky did the last one,
but it's also for an athlete,
especially a fighter where your mind and
you,
first of all,
you have this event that happens and I
don't have to tell you this,
but for everybody listening it happened.
It takes months before the event.
You're thinking about this event.
We're preparing for the event and an
event is one night.
Anything that can fuck your head up
along the way should be avoided.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be thinking about getting
mass discounts on t bones and filet.
You should be really worried about
wonderful.
Anything.
Anything that could fuck you up.
You know,
there's so many different things that
can creep into your mind.
Will look great.
Transition.
Look at me.
Tate.
Yeah.
I told him I'm not taking anything away
from Pennington.
I thought she was brilliant.
She did her job.
I thought there was a real bad matchup
for me.
Show,
honestly.
Super underrated,
but she.
She's underrated for sure.
I also think that version of me shut.
I and I,
I just said that's Misha doesn't look
into it or something else is going on.
She said I'm an off night.
She,
it didn't look like the normal meesha
were used to seeing and for Misha for
her to say I'm done.
I didn't.
I couldn't hear it because again,
I was watching with a live crowd so I
can hit,
but she retired.
She retired.
When she say she was just like,
I'm out.
Yeah.
She says,
I just want to say I'm done.
I'm done.
And I said,
it was this based entirely on your
performance?
Is that something you planned?
And she said,
no,
it was based on my performance.
And then she said that I just,
I've taken a lot of punishment and I'm
fairman that's fair and she's also to me
she,
someone you,
you want your daughters to look up to.
Like she's such a great face for women's
MMA just because obviously she's a
beautiful young lady.
Probably the best looking one the UFC,
but she also,
she speaks very well.
She has the skills.
You're talking about a lady who,
if you would've told her she'd been
champion in the UFC,
you know,
after you've seen our fights with ron
and these other fights,
she,
I'm sure she.
I'm like,
you're full of shit.
And she just came back from adversity
like when she beat Holly.
Amazing,
amazing man.
And for her now there's so much more for
her to do this why I'm proud of her and
her getting out when she did because I
don't know if you've heard her breakdown
fights as a female analyst.
She is so damn good.
It's ridiculous.
She's very smart.
She's very good at breaking down the
fights as far as not like Joe Rogan
style.
Uh,
Brian Stann style dump.
Krista.
She's good as a,
as an analyst on when she's up there
with like Stan and business and those
guys.
And have you had on your show?
We have not had another show.
I listened to her on your show and I
thought she was brilliant.
She's got her own show now too.
Does she?
Has she has her own podcast?
Yeah.
Well she's already doing it the right
way.
But um,
I,
I think for her man,
like sky's the limit.
I really do.
You're right.
I think you're right.
And I think if she really mean,
everybody always says that if you have
one foot out the door,
you should just walk,
just go there.
You go here.
And that's why he sent me down here.
Well excuse me sir.
You're telling Dick Jokes and trying to
fight right now.
What's one thing?
Watching somebody who you don't love
who's just like,
well you know,
or even you do love,
you don't have that close of a
relationship with.
But as a friend,
you know,
you have a close friendship with
someone.
You see the path.
I mean it's one of those things,
man,
you see it time and time again.
I,
I can name you 100 guys that I know that
are kind of half in the game.
Oh yeah.
And they still do it in every now and
then they get knocked out or they'll
fight some Yair,
Rodriguez type motherfucker.
Some upcoming lit up and all in.
Yeah.
Those all in guys are fucking scary.
And you know,
for me it was the best thing that ever
happened in my life.
So.
Well,
I think it's probably going to be the
best thing for me should too,
and one of the things that I said to me,
she was like,
you know,
you've already achieved the highest
achievement ever in mma.
You were world champion in the UFC.
So like you know that no one could ever
take that from her.
She wanted it in spectacular fashion and
it was an amazing accomplishment.
That's a giant thing to have on your
resume.
Former world champion and she's at the
perfect time.
Just talking about from a business side
of things is the,
the UFC contract with Fox is,
is coming up.
So what they're going to do from my
understanding is it's going to be on
multiple networks,
so it's going to be like the NFL or Mba
or whatever these other sports leagues
with just tied to Fox,
which opens up the door for espn,
CBS,
all these other networks.
So that opens up the door for all these
other shows for her.
So if I,
if I'm a Misha tate,
I don't sign with Fox right now.
She's the best female analyst in the
game to me.
I think she waits to that deal,
goes and then fields all the offers and
she has the time to do it.
She might or UFC might offer some sort
of an in house Gig,
you know,
who knows?
I could see that saying,
don't do that,
don't do that man.
The farmer manager don't do that.
Let them play the negotiating game and
she has so many talents and no one's
coming along like crew who speaks or it
looks like her.
Yeah.
It wasn't that happening with you guys.
Isn't there a network issue?
Yes.
There is some sort of an issue with you
guys being on Fox for,
for us it's just a brag.
Don't talk about that.
A Rogan and we before.
I'm like,
we got to talk about it and you don't
mean I'm an open book and I'm like,
do what?
You don't have to talk about it if you
don't want to know.
I know we always talk about,
for me it's just a um,
you know,
I'm always,
I'm always in the understanding of we
don't need anybody and you've always
said that and I think uh,
the fire and the kid fan base and,
and what we've achieved has literally
nothing to do with Fox,
you know,
they gave us a studio and I,
and,
and I'm grateful for that stuff,
but we would be here with or without
them,
you know,
studios not that big a deal.
You just want to rent office space.
A lot of guys,
we all know people that do it.
Tom and Christina do it.
Joey Diaz does it.
I do.
A lot of people do it.
They just rent space,
correct.
Not Hard to do.
No.
And you know,
we,
our biggest issue would be finding a,
a good producer to help us,
like a young Jamie you would have to do
is put out the ad,
throw the bat signal up online.
I'm sure this,
here's the best signal signal we're
looking for one.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you find someone who knows how to
handle the internet side of things and
I'm sure Jamie can help them,
what's going on today?
That's really interesting,
and podcasting,
and we've kind of talked about this
before,
but is that the real network is the
organic network between friends?
Correct.
It's between all of us.
Between Joey and bill burr and Bert
Kreischer and Thompson.
We're all just a bunch of friends and we
talk about each other and we have each
other on and everybody finds out about
each other from each other and we
retweet each other and re instagram each
other and support each other and that's
not like a real network where there's no
deals going on.
There's no paper signed.
It's an and then everybody sort of
benefiting from it.
Equally,
everybody gets something out of it,
you know?
That's a real network.
This other thing is a weird business.
We're noncreative people capitalize on
the work of creative people and they
provide you with what?
A fucking series of walls and an
Internet connection.
Oh,
thank you for that.
You definitely should get half the money
out of your fucking mind.
That's exactly what I said.
I,
it,
it's just a different age now that,
that,
that we're going into.
And um,
it's,
we're in a good spot.
That's a good thing.
We're in a good spot and we have offers
from all these other networks and stuff
like that.
So that's all good in the hood.
The most important thing is just you
guys love what you do and the show is
fun and that's the biggest thing and
then people are going to still enjoy it.
So it's almost like,
think about it as little as you can.
I guess for me,
I see it as a opportunity.
Like when,
when we were discussing it today,
I was excited.
I'm like,
Oh yes,
you kind of get our Joe Rogan now,
Jack,
you got to do that for sure.
A lot of guys have done.
Then you know,
my friend Dave Rubin,
who was on last week,
he had a similar situation.
He was with one network.
He left that and went with another
network and he was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
And I told him,
I'm like to just keep,
just be free.
You just get out there.
Well,
I think what people don't is like all
the guests,
the marketing,
the merchandise,
like I have five hired our own booker.
We found our own published.
Like it's all in house.
It's all whatever I want to do with it.
Like we literally just show up to the
studio.
I can't imagine how they thought that
they'd get 50 percent of that.
It's so crazy.
It's insane.
It's just maybe they just don't know how
much money it is or they don't.
I was literally laughing,
like physically laughing,
like,
oh,
you have to resolve it.
How'd you end it?
Now it's off to the agents call agent.
Like there you go,
man.
I should have never brought you in the
first place at all.
That stuff's supposed to be done with
agents and that's supposed to bring you
in and talk financials with you with no
representation.
Correct.
However,
I'm very,
and if to almost to a fault,
I'm very in on as far as the business
side.
Things go with fighter and the kid like,
I want to be involved now.
Now when it goes to negotiate,
uh,
you guys do that,
if you want to change the logo from a
maroon to an orange,
you better fucking go over it with me.
If you do some without me knowing that,
then we have issues.
Do they think they can do that kind of
shit though?
Do you think that they would start doing
that if they did it once and I was like,
well what did they do?
They,
uh,
they changed something if some logo,
they tweeted something out that I didn't
approve and you know,
you can call me a control freak,
but.
So this is like the network did that.
Fox.
Yeah.
Well they have certain people run the,
the,
the accounts,
you know.
So they just decided that they were
like,
uh,
what are you doing?
You know what I'm saying?
So,
well that's,
you're in a weird gray area,
you know,
you have your own show.
You have a very limited amount of people
that are in charge of that show,
but all these other people that are sort
of used to like if they have a show,
they get a say they.
I mean I remember when they were telling
you not to swear.
Yeah.
Other than that they sent you is for you
guys to go get free money.
You've been saying that forever.
No swearing.
I know,
I know.
It makes it.
Makes the audience like almost you think
they're stupid or they can't handle the
swear words.
People were getting upset.
It takes away everything.
That's great about the Internet.
What's great about the Internet is you
just.
You can be yourself.
You got to be.
You be yourself in.
But also what they don't realize any.
Again,
it's just an old school way of thinking.
They don't realize how big podcasting is
getting because whether I'm at Fox,
I'm in Joe Rogan's bathroom doing the
podcast.
The listeners just want the audio,
you know?
They just want the show.
They don't do it.
Fucking do it.
I got a little microphone that I hook up
to this fucking thing.
To my bill.
Burn does,
Dude.
It's amazed.
Just goes off his iphone like a maniac
and it still works.
Mark.
Man,
does that have a garage for God's sakes?
That's a president in his garage.
Well,
he's actually got a pretty sweet setup.
No,
he really does.
But you get the point.
I'm gonna.
Try to find this shit in here.
I'll show you what this thing is.
Yeah,
it's just,
it's just a different kind of day and
age of media and we're in a good spot,
man,
so I'm happy to.
I just don't think that this.
I'll find it later,
but it wasn't meant.
Gets a microphone talking about fits
into here and it has a built in little
tripod on it because I think it's called
an apogee or something like that here.
You ever used the zoom mic?
Yeah,
Brian.
I start a zoo.
Mike in his garage.
Yeah.
It's just you don't need much.
You don't need much.
I mean we're trying.
Obviously we're trying to go the
fricking jre experience and then Jamie
told me how much that God damn mother
ship board is over them.
We'll probably,
I'll probably see if I can get that at a
goodwill or something like that.
Sweat this,
this whole thing,
right?
Like this.
See this all Jeremy,
this all microphone.
I take this to the microphone.
I screwed into here.
This little baby here is a little
fucking tripod.
Sits on it.
All kinds of little case.
I popped that sucker down.
He could set it up in a hotel room.
Damn son.
That's what you did on the plane when we
were Dana and Tony know they'll on a
plane with Deana and Tony.
I didn't even have this yet.
Damn.
Of things.
Dope Dude.
It's the shit.
Wow.
Tightened it down.
What's it called?
It's called the apogee or something like
that.
I set that up and it's a real live
condenser microphone and it picks up all
the voices.
Claire through your phone.
That's.
That's really incredible.
That's really cool.
You need like,
you don't need all this other shit.
We do all this other shit because even
way,
way back in the day.
I was like,
why wouldn't we have a visual element of
it?
Why wouldn't we have like a.
We were doing the streaming version of
it even even actually before we were
doing anything else.
Visuals,
big donor or youtube,
you need the visual aspect of it for
sure.
Like you can't downgrade now but,
but also for us it's just um,
yeah,
you just want to continually,
continually get better key park in baby.
I can't believe they didn't fire us.
I have to set some outlandish shit on
that show.
I can't believe fluxing like,
listen,
why don't we just can't have it?
Well,
I don't think they pay attention or
yeah,
they know the numbers so they know the
numbers.
That's one thing they do know because
you're on their network.
So the Lord Jesus is because there's not
another thing that they have,
especially kind of down.
There was a time there when I,
especially right when I retired and I
was like,
you know,
I was angry.
I was angry at certain things may not
lash out on the mic and stuff like that.
Especially in their office,
in cahoots with the UFC.
So how they didn't fire me,
I have no idea.
Well,
I think the worst thing could be that
they did fire you.
It's actually smart.
They didn't because you know what the
streisand effect is.
Yeah.
Like when you see now band me and I went
howling like a little owl to everybody.
You know,
there's,
there's a bunch of examples of things
like that that have happened where
someone gets bigger because like Milo
Yiannopoulos,
you know,
he is.
Yeah.
He got banned from twitter,
banned from twitter because he was
making fun of ghostbusters.
Became bigger than ever became like this
cultural icon because it's publicity.
You can't pay for it.
Look at Ariel Hawaii.
Bad example in Hawaii.
Do you remember when the use banned him?
Kicked him out and they went on.
All those networks use like my bad.
My bad.
Your backend?
Yeah,
for a little while.
And now he's.
Is he out again?
Yeah.
Again,
because of the brock lesnar thing.
Remember when he was in New York?
I don't think so.
Was He there in the arena?
Did he have press credentials?
I saw him walking around like,
oh,
he was fired from Fox.
That's what he was fired from Fox.
Yeah,
yeah,
but not fired from his shot and doing
the UFC me.
So he's banned from being in the media
for a little while.
Then they let them back in and it works.
Yeah.
But the thing is in,
in Dana's defense and the ucs defenses,
the NFL,
you know,
certain leagues do that.
They don't,
they don't allow certain people in.
So it's not like as much as North Korea
is that we thought like there's,
there are leaks.
Who Band guys from coming to the events?
Well I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck the NFL does,
so it's not even worth me talking about
it.
How about Habib number?
Good men off the fucking scary monster
that guys.
But here's the thing,
he did get clipped,
slept.
Michael Johnson clipped him and I'm
watching that.
I was like,
what would connor due to this kid bright
because before I'm like kind of get
marked by Khabib.
And I saw him like,
well if Johnson lands that you bet your
sweet ass connor's going to land that
magical lefthand.
I'm,
I'm done questioned what conner's
capable of because I was like,
Eddie is a tough matchup.
I think he's gonna win this one.
I do.
God Damn.
I'm scared for this fight.
I kind of want to see him fight Woodley.
I'd love to see him fight Brock Lesnar.
I want to see him take months off.
I wanted to see him take six months off
and bulk up.
You know what's crazy?
A little bit of meat.
It's not that outlandish to see that
that's possible.
No,
it's not.
It's totally possible.
The,
the,
the hiccup in that is the UFC is like
how do we just let him get all the belts
and all the control,
like where do we stop it before,
before he's running this stuff to give
up one of his belts to take on another
one.
He needs to get about 45,
45,
45.
He's never going to fight there again.
He might know that that cut down a tough
match,
but the cuts different now because
you're allowed to begin your rehydration
much earlier.
You can weigh in at 8:00
in the morning,
eight to 10 in the morning.
So by the time the ceremonial way in
rolls around,
it was in New York City at 6:00
PM.
He was full.
I mean he looked great.
He didn't look dehydrated at all at 55.
But even at 55 you used to look
dehydrated,
right?
Not too bad.
40th five.
He lived near the door of death and also
start.
We've never really seen him at 55 in the
UFC.
I haven't seen him in case or some other
organization.
So it was 45.
It just,
I don't see how even makes it even as
camps,
like,
dude,
it's way too tough on him.
Just let that belt go though.
Now you did your thing.
Let it go because you're keeping that
division hostage.
You got pedes Max Holloway coming up.
It's funny.
I think it's hilarious too.
It's funny because it's not my
lifestyle,
but if I was,
although I'd be fucking freaking out,
although he was the champ forever three
match so bad it ain't happening because
he really retired.
He retired and then thought he was going
to go do something else,
and he was like,
and that he thought the use was like,
oh,
okay,
do your thing.
And then he realized how tough those
contractors and came back.
He's like,
well,
looks like I have to fight and let's do
it.
You know,
like,
who's he gonna fight.
I wonder if Petterson Holloway always
been knocking on the fucking door for a
long time,
man.
Nine straight.
How he does this ridiculous.
Just needs a bigger name.
He just,
he just,
he needs getting more famous.
That's the day and age when he just
asked to get famous or get on the mic,
talk some shit.
I'm really interested to see him versus
pedes pedes.
I think it's real diminished by that.
Cut.
I agree.
That's a hard cut for him to get on 45.
And um,
I love this man.
I'm a huge fan,
but I,
he hasn't looked the same as of late.
Max Holloway is a slick motherfucker
too.
You realize it now after you watch
Frankie Edgar and Jeremy Stevens fight,
you realize how Slick Holloway is.
It was never in trouble in that fight,
never went.
And then also think about his last last
was conor mcgregor.
Conor,
how jacked up knee,
but I went to decision the only decision
congress had in the UFC and think how
much better Max Holloway's now.
Yep.
If he wins this one,
dear God,
if someone's listening to that,
get a title shot.
Yeah.
What's you have to do?
I know.
What do you do with Tony and Khabib
though?
You're talking about too crazy wind
streaks to like how do you even just
making flight has.
That's the life thing.
You make them fight,
fight,
but let's say you had to pick one of
them.
If is a guy off at 55 and three months.
Who the fuck wants some?
Well,
right now,
before that fight,
Tony Ferguson was the number one
contender.
Rightly so.
Just beat Hoffeld.
Dos Anjos beat a shitload of guys.
He's so active.
Your speed.
Edson Barboza,
he was the number one contender
according to whatever the rankings are,
which I don't think are accurate.
All of a sudden toss some of them kind
of.
So yeah.
But the second position right now,
if he's still number one,
is clearly habib.
Habib was number one,
but have has been way more inactive than
Tony.
But the way a be mauled.
Michael Johnson,
I think he makes his case.
That was an old hall.
We both have a cake ones.
Undefeated ones on knife fight,
win streak.
And then Tony,
you know,
I thought he dismantled RDF.
It looked great.
Amazing.
Khabib.
Absolutely.
Ragdolled dos Anjos two and then fucking
make a destroy.
Johnson was horrible.
Watching them beat up Johnson because
he.
He's so good at tying up that one arm.
He ties up the one arm then fucking
smashes.
You.
Wish you had them in mountain home with
one arm.
Try to protect them and he's getting
just thumped in the head.
It's got a hold of that chicken wing.
Other than snap that bitch up.
Yeah.
That's not good.
I thought it was too,
but they'd tap.
Please tap.
It was like brave heart.
Just come on man.
Say it deep.
It was so deep too.
I was thinking Nog when Nog and Frank
Mir fall.
That's what I was thinking.
I was like,
this is going to snap,
but like same with Henzel,
whether you refused the tap,
I get that you're pursuing Jiu Jitsu to
the day you die.
Like with trump saying let's go ahead
and tap those,
sir.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm glad he tapped me to.
I was literally squeezing my hands
together when I was doing the
commentary.
I'm come on tap.
Come on top just to let now thing.
It's just when he got them down and then
immediately slid right into mounted
guillotine.
I was like,
Jesus Christ and his GRANDPA.
Ridiculous.
So good.
His grappling.
It's confusing.
I don't.
Yeah.
If so,
why?
Those two?
Fighting the fight.
Fight conor and Habiba the fight.
That's the,
that's not happening,
but I think Khabib needs to get the
title,
uh,
to get a title shot.
At least that's what I think.
I think you should.
I think he deserves it.
He's the only undefeated challenger.
He's a monster.
He's mauled everybody in front of him.
He hasn't had a single God damn close
fight.
He said one moment,
one moment where he gets dinged,
but you're,
you're talking,
you're speaking logically.
You think getting guys that deserve it.
Well,
we're.
We're an entertainment,
sir.
Just the same way conor leapfrogged.
Everyone got the title shot.
Listen to what I'm saying to you right
now.
The UFC is about to go to Russia.
Do you know that?
Yeah.
They want to get in.
The downloads are going to do it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
To see in Russia,
conor mcgregor versus Habib Yarmulke met
off.
That's what I think is common gi.
There's a lot of rush.
Just shy kids got on the mic right?
And was like,
yeah,
you know how much bigger fucking Russia
is than Ireland,
but he's not the same star.
Well here's the rushes bigger than
Ireland,
but the United States bigger than
Ireland too.
And when fucking connor is fighting in
New York City,
which is an hour and a half from Eddie
Alvarez House,
they're booing.
Eddie Alvarez is walking to the cage.
It doesn't matter.
Russia,
China,
Korea.
Ireland is the biggest star by far.
I don't know about that.
When you go to Russia,
I wonder if he gets booed in Russia,
don't you think if Kobi was that big of
a star in Russia,
maybe.
Maybe it's a sanction and stuff and they
are going there.
If you check my instagram page every
time a fucking photo gets up,
I know time,
reading time.
I agree.
King.
No,
he champ.
He deserves it,
but there's a reason why it hasn't been
the headline of a paper view.
Maybe in the states here.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe,
but he is a fucking monster and he's a
hero to the Russian mma fans.
Correct.
This guy from Dagestan has been mall in
everybody.
They put in front of them and people
think and rightly so,
that he's unjustly keeping being kept
rather from a title shot.
We can't say it's been kept from Natasha
and he's been injured for a long.
That's true too.
Who's keeping them from getting injured?
The blame.
Then a AK.
That's not commerce.
That's true,
but they did promise him this fight.
This was something that they said,
no,
Habib gets the next shot.
The title.
This was something that was publicly
stated,
which made sense at the time because
it'd be was 23 and he's going to fight
massive square garden for the title
because what they were saying,
talking about the connor versus Eddie
Alvarez can't have that.
That doesn't sell tickets exactly how it
went.
Nah,
I want to fight that with cookie.
We'll keep you on the car once you.
Once you find on the undercard though,
I imagine how he feels when he hears
that Shit,
man.
He gets that phone call.
He thinks this is it.
Finally I got the title.
He went in his backyard and beat the
shit out of Kodiak bear.
He said,
have you ever seen that video?
He was a kid.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
He's a kid.
So much tougher than anyone I know so
got into.
He's ridiculous.
His grappling is ridiculous and I'm
really interested in seeing whether or
not he can get past that lefthand and I.
If you are correct and that's the fight
in Russia,
the amount of money they're going to
have to pay connor to fight him in
Russia when connor is still the draw.
You're talking about a different
ballgame.
Show me the money.
It's going to be interesting though,
like what other Russian bad assets are
there?
They're fighting UFC.
Did you see that?
I'm a chorus.
Cough.
Just got knocked the fuck out in
Beltour.
Yes.
Which was crazy to Lima.
To him as a
bad motherfucker.
Of course.
Godzilla Monster.
Yeah.
Speaking of Russians are in that area.
And not to flip the script here,
but this weekend is Andre Ward verse.
I'm fricking Kovalev boxing match up a
long time.
No one's talking about either.
That's not.
I know.
I've been watching all the countdowns
and shit.
I can't get enough of it.
I know.
I've watched that last countdown thing.
They did too.
It was on after the um,
Victor Ortiz fight.
Yeah.
It looked like shit.
Well,
the duty fall was like on sort of
survival mode.
He was terrified.
He didn't throw any punches,
nothing.
They sit through the whole fight.
He threw 100 and something.
He was so scared and then Ortiz was
touching me.
Pretend to fall down because he's like
waiting for.
Lydia was grabbing his head.
San Diego hit in the back of the head a
couple of times.
It was a terrible fight.
Wasn't good,
but yet you're right.
Right after that was Andre Ward Kovalev
like the countdown,
kind of their background and Andre Ward.
To me,
he's just a bigger version of floyd
mayweather.
Like his defense is insane.
He has knockout.
Power isn't lost since he's 13.
I give him the advantage.
Some people think a cove to when I don't
know what the betting odds are.
I was stunned.
By the way [inaudible] handled hopkins
and I know Bernard's old.
He's 100 years old.
It was a thousand.
It looks like a turtle.
He looks old.
He was fighting again,
December 10th or twelfth in La.
You're not going to lie.
I'm not going to that sort of leader.
I'm going to be in.
That's the Toronto UFC that weekend.
It's also the weekend of glory.
That's Badr Hari versus Rico Verhoeven.
Was that the best weekend ever?
Besides that,
I've been site.
That's a good fucking car.
That Toronto card is static.
It is now because you've got Kennedy
shot,
cowboy,
Matt Brown cowboy versus Matt Brown is
better than cowboy versus gasoline.
100.
That fight did nothing for me.
Well,
gaslamp's done now man.
He's in a bad,
bad,
bad place.
Dana says 85.
Now he's missed.
He's said that before and made him fight
85 mayberry beat.
Nate Marquardt a five.
Correct.
So it wasn't a 5:35.
Mark know if my mark artist 70 was it?
Yeah,
it was one of those fights that he beat
somebody because he got sent up to 85.
Then he proved that he could make the
weight and he's blaming George Lockhart
now.
Now the only person you can blame is
yourself.
Like,
you know,
man,
especially being an experiences,
you know.
And that's.
It's so frustrating.
That shows you.
What kind of car do you have?
C,
two.
A five was I'd even blink to.
I didn't bat an eye that.
Alright,
what's next?
Look at this fucking car.
I know Tim Kay were shot.
That sucks.
Oh my God.
Look at this card.
Yeah.
Well now Toronto's just gassed.
Alum is a really elite fighter.
He's a very tough guy,
tough guys.
I'm a big fan of.
That kid I think is awesome,
but he needs to lose some fucking body
fat.
Period.
You're not a heavyweight.
You're not Cain Velasquez.
He can't walk around with that much body
when he posts on instagram like a week
before,
two weeks before a fight,
like real Mexican dinner.
It's like these fucking Burritos,
enchiladas stuff,
man.
We can't have that.
We cannot have that.
Can do that.
He,
I mean he's an elite professional
athlete who absolutely could.
Still to this day when the world title
he has a skill for has the scale and
he's
fought the guys.
He beat Woodley.
Yeah.
Did he it the decision decision where he
didn't fucking make weight.
There you go.
That was a decision where he didn't
fucking make weight and Woodley being a
great guy that he is.
Didn't take the percentage.
Thirty percent.
Yeah.
20.
I think it is.
When your opponent doesn't make her
wait.
Still a persistent 30,
30.
I thought it was 20.
Um,
Woodley being a great guy.
He has said I don't want that money.
And he beat him by decision because.
So will he got the win bonus too?
But Calvin,
I don't know who calvin is fought at 85
in the last few years,
but he's been forced at one point in
time to go up to 85.
She needs to fucking lose body fat.
Just lose it and keep it off dude.
And any time a fight,
it doesn't make wait.
Mike Dolce jumps out like Chris Hanson
from to catch a predator.
Excuse me to take a seat.
You want to sit down and he,
he cannot wait to tweet out.
Ah Man.
It's frustrating when guys.
Ms Dot Wade.
Yeah he does.
He is just super thirsty and nice.
Chris Hansen,
I catch a predator.
Just fucking can't wait to tweet about
it.
Will don't you?
He's got a whole staff.
He's got a staff of people.
He's expensive but yeah,
he's got a.
well it is expensive for a reason.
It's kind of.
It's got an office building.
Well he's an employee of the UFC too.
Well I think he has like nine employees
or something crazy.
Just looking up.
Shoot to fucking lose weight and shit.
Yeah,
but it comes out of the curtain.
So a lot of sway disagree with him
though.
A lot of people disagree with some of
his methods and lock arms.
Bj Penn.
Yeah.
Well he was.
He was just upset that.
Well he was upset for a bunch of
reasons.
You need to wait though,
but he was upset.
They don't charge them so much and you
knoW that he really didn't do much.
I don't know the whole story.
I don't know the whole story either.
I'm not taking sides there,
but I will tell you this.
Bj penn's tHat got damn legend.
So I'm siding with him usually he's from
Hawaii.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck happened
either.
You'd have to be there,
but the point is like if you have
someone who is monitoring every aspect
of your weight,
cut like your hydration levels with
what,
what kind of fluid you're drinking,
what kind of foods you're eating and it
doesn't work out.
If you did what that guy said and the
weight didn't come off,
somebody fucked up who fucked up.
I don't know.
It'd be the case,
but let me ask you this,
joe,
if some,
if,
if let's say it's not ufc 205 this week
by 10 pounds though,
which is ridiculous,
but let's say it's not use to.
If I were to card not a stack,
let's say it's a main event in toronto,
uh,
with dc and a grumble,
which before that card was pure shit.
Besides that fight now to amazing card,
yet metallica,
anthony pettis,
blah,
blah.
Would it be crazy for the new ufc suits
to hire nutritionist and they,
for those maybe just the main card,
they designate you a guide to help you
lose weight because it's your product.
It's not a bad idea.
However,
I think maybe michael j.
It works with everyone and he has a
team.
Maybe it's not my dolce,
but he's writing the plan.
This your diet and this person is
assigned to you and they're following up
with you because who it hurt when they
don't make weight,
it hurts the fighter and then it hurts
the ufc to sign cards.
I think an even better strategy is seek
to eliminate weight cuts.
Seek to cut it out of sport.
It's unnecessary.
It's dangerous.
It puts guys at risk health wise when
they don't have to be at risk health
wise.
If I think the only thing that's holding
it back,
our championship belts and more options
await classes.
I think if they could figure out what
wait guys are where they compete at
optimally and then the same way you do
us a da or usada testing.
You do hydration testing,
but how.
But how many weight class you'd have to
give these guys killing weight class?
Yes.
Yep.
You have.
You have more weight class with any of
boxing?
No,
that's what's the problem.
It's not a problem with boxing.
They'll look and they're going to fight
you.
Will you have less organizations?
It's not like you have five different
world title organizations and plus
weight classes.
You would just have plus weight classes.
I think you would have more champions.
You'd have more opportunity for
championship titles.
I liked that because was stars.
You also have more opportunity for,
you know,
title bouts between guys where the one
guy decides to go up.
One guy said to go down,
but instead of them doing it by
dehydrating themselves,
24 hours out,
you make a contract to fight at a
certain weight because that's what way
you are in a healthy way,
which is which maximizes their skills
and performance and it doesn't put them
into the dangers that you have from
being dehydrated 24 hours out.
I Think if just the ufe will look like.
How many weight classes do you have?
Where a good question.
You know what I'm saying?
that's one belt.
I think boxing has many and it's a real
problem name,
but it's.
I don't care.
Name 10 stars in the ufc like you want
me to?
Yeah.
Okay.
10 champions will tend to be in the
former case in boston named champions
and former champions easily.
Don't you think you could name 10
champion boxer,
so manny pacquiao.
Bradley,
if you want to start going on.
Terrence crawford has co facility has
seven floyd mayweather.
You know you can keep going.
You can name a bunch of champions in
boxes.
Little.
All those guys run in the same way.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
But you know,
you go up and heavyweight,
you got fucking klitschko wilder.
Got to joshua's week.
Oh,
you did it.
What's up?
Let's go chill.
That's amazing.
Must be here today.
But uh,
he had to move it to.
Well,
yeah,
he's fighting for a world title.
Brilliant.
Interesting.
That's going to be fun.
Yeah.
There's a lot of heavyweight talent now.
Anthony.
Joshua is a bad motherfucker.
Like,
yeah,
that guy in a fricking New Zealand that
everyone talks about is tyson fury doing
a.
He's retired and clinically like he,
he's suicidal and need some help
mentally.
It's just not there.
well,
so he's out.
No,
don't.
It's crazy man.
That dude's crazy.
Characters like that.
But I,
I,
I liked idea of job,
but the problem is it's stuff enough for
that are trying to keep up now with the
stars.
I think that's the least of our
concerns,
the most important things to put on.
Great fights.
So higher kids.
How many,
how much dehydration?
dehydration is dangerous and unnecessary
ones died that they have in Brazil.
I think it can come close to the ufc,
but it hasn't even been done.
Do you want to dos anjos passed out for
three fucking minutes before his fight
with eddie alvarez where it was
unconscious and unresponsive,
but did you die?
he was on the doorbell,
Nobody's died,
but people have been diminished
considerably and I think they're know
for their performance suffers,
so it makes it makes a shittier product.
I think if you want to look at it from a
business plus,
if the ufc has got look,
you could say,
hey,
steroids are part of the game.
Are they?
Well,
not anymore.
Now they're fucking knocking on your
door at 6:00
in the morning and making peanut cup.
If they decided to do that at 6:00
in the morning,
they'd try to test people's hydration
levels at 6:00
in the morning every day and when I
would find out what your weight is,
okay,
this is what your body fat is,
this is what your weight is,
this is the lowest you can get.
You can get,
you know,
they'll test you out when you're fully
hydrated and when your,
your body fat is,
you know,
wherever the fuck you are right now,
they'll say,
hey,
okay,
right now you're 178 pounds.
LIsten to lowest you can fight is one
72.
That's it.
You're going to have 1000 weight
classes.
Guys won't fight each.
I don't know about that.
I think guys,
some guys could gain a little weight.
That's no big deal.
So guys,
I don't mind the idea.
I think you're right.
You're going to get great performances.
Way better performances.
I think the weight class thing because
your thing to do is.
I agree they often need to do something,
but I think right now the easiest thing
to do for them is to use whoever they
want doesn't have to be like dolce.
Put a number of them and assIgn those to
the main card guys to make sure they're
coming on weight.
Yeah.
But what about the guys on the undercard
fuck them.
That sounds crazy to me because that's
what they did with reebok.
Does it sound like crazy to say fuck
them?
Yes it does,
but that's the nature of the beast,
but I think that's crazy.
Too crazy.
I'm just following the orders.
I understand that,
but I'm saying if.
If I had the master key,
the first thing I would do is say come
up with a strategy to stop weight
cutting.
We're going to come up with a new plan
and whether that new plan means
abandoning world titles and making care.
Yes.
Now you introduce someone as a world
champIon.
You know whoever the fuck they are,
they get to bring their world title to
the fight,
but whenever their next title defenses
or whatever the fuck it is,
all this name stuff,
welter,
light feather.
First of all,
it's goofy because it's not the right
weight.
Anyway.
Welterweight is not one 70.
It's 1:47.
That's what sugar ray leonard and thomas
hearns fatah.
They called it fucking welterweight to
start the ufc and just to say,
well,
it's welterweight and then pride fucked
it up even more because they had it.
It was different,
like their middle weight was two.
Oh,
three.
Correct.
Like when the light heavyweight two.
Oh,
five.
one 75.
He knows that heavyweights two.
Oh,
one plus we grew up in Boxing
and then the weight classes were clearly
defined.
Why the fuck does ufc have a 265 pound
weight limit to why you making brock
lesnar cut weight or whoever the fuck.
A big giant dude is like.
Shane,
why would you make shane cut wave?
He wants to weigh 300 pounds.
Let that fucking big vanilla gorilla
with 300 pounds.
I want to see it.
Dude.
He has a matchup and rising.
I just saw it.
Someone said,
I haven't seen.
Dude,
I've never heard of.
I've never heard him.
I guess he's just some fucking middle
eastern monster.
Oh no.
He's an olymPic level wrestler and just
knocks dudes out.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
I don't.
I,
I need to research on the guy,
but someone tagged me and I'm like,
oh my god.
I thought it was fate.
or though that's a big name matches.
It's a tournament style where you just
winter don't fight,
fade or it's supposed to be like a open
wait tournament.
It's dope.
What kind of work is shane had done his
back?
Uh,
he had surgery.
I know you had a disc replacement and
then hit some stuff on his neck.
He had a disc replacement.
Pretty sure.
Like they put a,
one of those artificial jammies in
there.
Uh,
I don't want to speak for him,
but he had surgery on his that didn't
get it and did it.
The anything fuSed.
I'm not sure.
I don't wanna speak for shade.
I know he had surgery on his back.
Yeah.
I like rising because they let them take
all the vitamins you want it.
It's just.
I mean it's just a monster squad that
they should rename it.
Monsters inc overeem to go over there to
me to just do the old thing.
You just do a little thing like the old
time you need for gita in the face and
ended his life.
Do that.
Yeah.
when he fought todd duffy and he looked
like some sort of a cartoon character.
how fun was that?
Marrow looks small compared to them.
Yoel romero looked malnourished.
man,
it looks like he has aids next uber
rating.
God damn fucking hit the gym.
Uber rich.
We've never seen anything like it.
Whatever reason when you and I together,
we just fucking have a love fest over
this uber ring.
Paul doesn't exist in the lochness
monster.
Obsessed with this.
Well,
this video though,
that's the problem.
There's not just like we see them and
we'll go,
oh,
that's the guy steve pages.
I'm telling you.
Steve pays a bad motherfucker.
No doubt about it.
But he's not the same guy.
That's not the brock lesnar guy.
Brock.
Nah,
they got.
Doesn't exist anymore.
Like I was tearing.
He did.
He would never lose.
Never ever lose.
I was so scared because I was fine at
that time.
I was like,
well,
what the fuck would happen?
What if they called me up right now?
I'm going to Have to act sick.
Yeah.
well,
yeah.
it's interesting,
man.
That's,
that's not the people that saY that
steroids don't win.
Fights are performance enhancing.
Drugs don't wIn fights.
They're crazy.
Those people are crazy.
Crazy.
You're out of your mind.
You're crazy.
Helps a lot.
You don't think I could have went uber
brown,
uber big brown.
Oh yeah,
rondae brown.
It helps a lot.
[inaudible] brown would do some work.
It also helps with your chair.
Yes,
and hopefully I could have taken that
hah and my head would have grown,
so all of a sudden I this ubering body
and this Mark Hunt had.
That'd be fucking.
You know what I hope honestly,
I really do hope that rise and takes off
and becomes like pride was back in the
day and you have these nutty,
insane fucking full bore freak show
fights and we get to see guys just jack
sat in my life.
That'd be awesome.
We would do fucking pants.
So sick.
Fuck Yeah.
It'd be so violent.
It'd be amazing.
If ufc was smart,
they'd get in bed with them and be like,
listen,
let's put me under the table.
Investors bring this over to fucking
fight pass.
Come on baby.
I agree.
Hey listen.
Ubering want start some shit.
How about you get your science?
And they'll put it on flight and
encourage the steroids.
Say,
listen,
I know those motherfuckers kid can't
fight like that over here.
We're all cleaning,
so listen,
just fucking give us a little taste.
It'd be a good business plan.
Yes.
Yeah,
you can watch the freak show.
You get it.
Companies freak show you get it all.
And who knows?
Man.
Japan is weird.
You know,
Japan was a huge culture for mma at one
point in time.
Like at one point in time the ufc was
giant over there and then it faded and
dropped off bat or excuse me,
a pride was giant and then it faded and
dropped off.
Bad and dream was kind of like the end
of it and then how there's not really a
presence there anymore until rising
comes along so verizon can figure out
how to bring back the same sort of
excitement in the japanese culture.
The japanese people that they had when
they had the pride days,
the glory days of selling outside thomas
super arena and those gigantic places.
Then it gives it.
It'd be good business for them because
then they just come in the back door and
like,
oh,
you liked that product.
what's the fellows to do it bigger and
better than.
You know what I'm saying?
A little piece of the.
I wonder how the ufc did because didn't
they do,
although foot,
uh,
someone out or not.
Although anthony pettis was the main
event out there.
Remember?
Yeah,
I was there.
I was there for what?
A good show.
While there has been more than one.
Japan,
ufc.
I've been there for one of them,
but that was the bit load.
The latest one.
Remember rampage fought when I was
there.
I remember that.
Um,
but I don't remember too much about that
event.
Mary pedis a pistol.
The main event and liver kick the shit
out of her head.
Kicks on.
It might've been um,
joe lozano.
Yes.
Maybe it was the car felt like roy was
on there to myosin.
I don't remember that.
I wonder what the numbers were like.
They couldn't have been too great.
[inaudible] ufc.
It was like,
ah,
we're good.
No,
because they haven't been back in
awhile.
I don't know.
I mean,
look,
the ufc does so many shows.
They're doing two next saturday.
They're doing one from Brazil and
they're doing one from belfast.
Really?
Yeah.
They're doing the northern Ireland card
is gay garden was saucy versus uriah
hall.
The rematch.
It's fun.
Yeah,
and then the Brazil card is ryan bader
versus little nog and claudia kadesia on
that car to.
And there's one more big fight on this.
Here's someone that no one's talking
about in the strawweight division is
jessica on drudge.
She moved down.
She's a girl,
a gorilla.
She,
her and liz carmouche that a
bodybuilding contest to stand in front
of each other.
Flex it out.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you,
I wouldn't mind seeing signed with the
ufc and I don't think she needs to work
on a stand up.
Obviously it's super amped right now,
but that mckenzie.
Oh yeah.
Is she?
I watched her,
I think it was on a hd net.
She plucking nodded this girl up and I
think it was a gogo plot and then she
got.
She started a gogo plata and then got
her neck.
Her grappling,
I think she could come into the ufc
right now it's straw weight and just top
five.
She was saying her jujitsu's insane.
It's so insane.
Hurt her striking super amateur.
But the straw weight divisions at a
point where I think she could still do
work right now and she's hot as fuck.
She is a smoke shop.
She's a smoke show and she speaks
english and portuguese fluently.
Dime pc and nasty on the ground.
Nasty when st.
Super high level black belt.
Then the daughter of megaton diaz?
Yes.
Who's a very,
very well respected,
famous presented jitsu black belt and a
pioneer.
He's one of the old school guys.
That's her papa.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
She,
yeah.
I think she's probably eventually gonna
wind up in the ufc.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Good luck taking down the polish killer.
Did you see the,
what she put on her fucking water
bottle,
bro?
yeah.
If somebody killer shit.
One of the guys from the underground
posted it up and then I actually wound
up getting it from um,
Joe Silva.
Joe silva showed it to me in between
fights.
It's um.
let me see the dude's name especially in
cognito is the dude's name on mixed
martial arts.com.
And it says in two days I will fuck a
bitch up and continue my violent run as
champion.
She writes that her water bottle just
straight,
cold blooded killer.
I love her.
But how much that fight?
I was surprised the first time we've
really seen her in a lot of trouble.
Like that.
She got crack.
Thing was a punch.
It was a straight punch.
She got hit by that punch.
The elbow like she,
she punched and came through with that
right elbow.
And then she was wobbly.
Man.
Maybe you've never really seen her in
that much danger.
You well.
And the thing was a shift.
Chanko was getting lit up for most of
the fights.
She's super tough.
Those polish move tough.
And after the fight look great.
I mean she had a lot of punches.
She had a lot of kicks.
Leg kicks,
ilana looked worse as far as face had
that big mouth on her upper.
Either she got cracked with.
I think there was a couple of hard
elbows in the clench too.
It was a great fight,
but it wasn't a great fight for awhile.
For awhile.
It was like it looked like valentino was
just.
She just wasn't as fluid or effective.
yes,
she was just hanging in there.
She never stopped.
She never stopped coming forward.
She never stopped coming forward and she
was never discouraged.
I mean she had some moments where she
couldn't solve the puzzle and you want.
It was doing a really good job of ending
the combinations with leg kicks inside
and outside.
Inside announcing stop.
Yeah.
And all those leg kicks were there.
There was.
There was really making a big
difference.
Yeah.
If you follow you on it though,
that,
that it was a,
it was a tough fight beyond definitely
one that she said like her first fight
with claudia kadesia.
That's how's the tougher fight for her.
She had a tough fight in the last one
with claudia.
Dahlia,
one really short one,
but yeah,
she's been to some wars.
Valerie letourneau.
She fought that fight.
She had a broken hand somewhere in the
fight.
She kept punching with it.
She's just a murder,
a man.
She's a bad ass woman.
It's as bad as tony hinchcliffe still
obsessed with her.
Loves her.
Like brother and sister though,
don't they?
Yeah.
It would be weird if they fucked.
She might not weigh him.
That's a tough one.
She's not cutting weight.
That's a tough one,
you know?
Yes.
She definitely beat his ass.
He admitted that he was like,
you know it your ass.
Right.
Mr.
Put her hands on your right.
He loves her man.
She's a killer.
Killer.
That was a long ass card though.
And what I was watching on the east
coast in Florida.
Dude,
the cards get done late there.
It's like 1:00
AM by the time connor was walking out.
Yeah.
Jamie was there.
We couldn't get somewhere to eat.
We try to get into the first restaurant
is goddamn packed at 2:00,
2:30
in the morning.
We wound up at katz's deli because
katz's deli is 24 slash seven.
We.
It was hard to find food.
It was mobbed.
I can't remember where his mom crazy.
How late it got done for these guys.
Will New York is different.
New york bars stay open I think till for
florida's till five.
Did you know that Florida was crap?
Florida was popping like everything was
great and I was exhausted going man,
two hours of sleep and got on a plane.
I was exhausted.
And then yeah,
especially if you're in southern
Florida.
Southern Florida is ridiculous where
we're at and then it's like that.
And then with the time change in la,
you know,
you just all messed up.
But that's why sports like in football,
but like the heisman voting and stuff
like that on these coasts,
it's so late you're like,
well I don't see a lot of it,
you know,
or they don't see a lot of the monday
night football or college games because
it's just so damn late.
Feel lIke there's a better route to go.
Uh,
nope.
That do it if it was right.
yeah.
Though the east coast doesn't mind
staying up late and the west coast
demands at beyond their schedule.
So it winds up starting at seven and
more people that's filmed things out
here.
Get points or.
yeah.
And if they did it on the,
the west coast of the east coast
schedule,
it happened too early.
You would lose money.
Like if you had a show at five,
people are not done working,
like people have to work on saturday.
They're still at work.
It's true.
So it can't be at four,
which would be,
if it was their time,
our time was 7:00
PM.
And then also you also have to think
about the undercard.
What if somebody wants to watch the
undercard on fs?
One,
you're not going to pay for the
undercard fs.
One is going to be,
hey listen bitch,
you can't put the undercard on a 10 in
the morning.
Nobody wants to watch that shit.
Done it.
Well,
you know when they're in Brazil,
it's actually like that,
but they'll get mad.
People get mad.
It's true.
You're going to get the mass audience is
obviously working.
Yeah.
And these coasts stays up.
They always stay up,
dude.
How crazy that matt square garden and
after the fight,
the lights on the state in which they've
never done before in the arena,
we're irish colors.
It was pretty intense.
Do you,
and brian and I were arguing this,
do you think conor mcgregor is more well
known than floyd mayweather?
Currently?
Yes.
Yeah.
boston's a bigger sport.
Yeah,
because you look at,
you look at floyd.
Manny,
like the patriot numbers destroys
anything cottage or been close to.
That's true.
Maybe not.
Maybe.
No.
I was arguing.
Connor is bigger.
He can social media,
stuff like that.
But floyd has more followers and and on
instagram,
twitter.
You can't judge it off that.
Here's the thing,
the amount of excitement that floyd
generates does not even fucking compare
to the amount of excitement that connor
generates.
It doesn't mean he's more popular.
Understand,
but it does kinda because the intensity
of the popularity.
The law.
People might know who floyd made with
her as,
but when it comes to how many people
love floyd mayweather.
It's not even close.
He might be like some ridiculous tend to
one or 20 to one because when connor
gets out there they go fucking crazy.
Crazy.
How many people were there to see floyd
mayweather lose?
How many people were bored after floyd
mayweather fights like ford mayor with
their fights so skillfully and
surgically that and doesn't take any
chances,
so hardly ever gets hit.
It's not connor merck's motherfuckers.
He wins the world title in the fastest
ever title,
winning knockout ever.
What did you do after that?
He comes back and makes eddie alvarez
looked like eddie alvarez world
champion.
The guy was,
he's defending delmar hall of famer and
connor makes him look like he has no
business in there with them.
No business has zero success at all
except for a couple of body shots.
This is why I think connor's bigger and
more trend descent because he just
bailed on that word.
I did.
Sorry.
transcendent,
transcendent be because I just bailed,
right?
Just fucking out like that.
I like.
I think I'm using it wrong and go and
operation he jacked,
but how many successful black athletes
do we know of?
Joe galen?
How many white irish superstars do we
know?
One?
Yeah.
One.
One weekend was a big star before he
came to the United States and he came to
the United States and eventually lost
his belt,
but barry mcguigan at one point in time
was a huge star,
but nowhere near to door that comes in
in,
in.
This goes for all athletes.
Conners the green elephant in the room.
everyone else we've seen before,
every once we,
we know what they can kind of do,
connors this green elephant amongst all
these gray elephants and there's nothing
like him.
Totally different.
Totally different animal.
It's crazy.
He's elephant with two fucking trunks to
15.
Dick's gold with a leprechaun outfit.
Correct.
And now he has a little son on the way
and they gave him a fucking rolls royce
with his face on it.
How crazy is that?
What's interesting is how well he
manages at all.
It's really interesting.
You know,
like the pressure in particular,
he doesn't seem to have a problem with
it at all.
It's weird.
That's what makes him so special because
that magnitude and the pressure and he
has to deliver and he has to do those
antics and then back it up.
But he keeps pulling it off like you at
the breast.
I was like,
right,
this is stupid and this getting old to
me.
But then when he pulls off,
I'm like,
that was brilliant.
And you know,
I mean the guy steps in,
he loses the ds,
right?
It takes the diaz fight on short notice.
By the way,
after a staph infection,
here's something that a lot of people
don't even know.
He had a pretty significant staph
infection was on antibiotics until like
two weeks before the fight.
If you don't think that drains your gas
tank,
he never had a staph infection and you
never had to take antibiotics.
Antibiotics are brutal on your,
on your respiratory system.
They're brutal on your whole body.
It's Just your body up.
Your body's made up of all this shit
that you don't consider to be you,
but it is you.
Stomach flora is a real part of you.
You know your body is essentially like
an ecosystem and when you have a staph
infection,
staph infections are dangerous as fuck
and people die from them.
You're so they hit you with some heavy
duty antibiotics.
I've had staff twice and it's not fun,
and the first time I had it and I took
the medication,
I couldn't believe how I felt so weird.
I felt light headed.
I felt weak.
I was like,
whoa,
I can drain.
Right?
You have no energy.
Super strong stuff too.
And I was like,
wow,
imagine this guy fighting two weeks
after that saying,
because there's no way you pete
correctly.
No.
so he comes from that and then he fights
nate again,
you know,
few months later in a fucking crazy five
round war and beat them by the narrowest
of margins.
Right.
Don't you agree?
Yeah.
That was very,
very close fight where some people
thought that nate one,
I mean very good.
But I thoUght the decision was correct,
but it was like,
wow,
that's close Fight.
So takes that fuCking crazy chance.
Comes back at fights.
That guy,
he kinda weighed one 69.
That's what he weighed when he weighed
in.
That's what he weighed during the fight.
And they,
they want them to fight at 55.
He goes,
no,
no.
I can be with seven.
Let me do 70.
Nate wade.
Probably around one 90 something.
Yeah,
I mean did,
I mean everybody says that nate is a 155
pounder.
He is 100 percent,
but he's away bigger man and been then
connor is,
he just is,
you know,
so it's like who's going to way more
when they actually get in there and
nate's gonna weigh more so he does that
and then goes from there and just say
starches.
Eddie alvarez like a world beater and
just so relaxed and loose in there.
So amazing.
Fucking madonna was at the show.
Madonna was done.
Show mcdonald's at the fights.
How crazy is that?
Mcdonald's instagramming mama.
We made it mama.
We made it red penny night.
It's red penny and I and madonna europe
thinks she's single.
Where the fuck is my second belt?
I envisioned this with a focus me nuts,
man.
It's fucking character,
He's such a character.
And,
and you know,
I thought he was gonna make a big
announcement.
I thought it was announcement was he's
going to retire,
but his nephew was like a,
if I'm going to continue doing this,
you guys need to.
I need a share of the company.
Yeah.
That's probably what the announcement
was going to be all along.
You know that he wants a piece of the
pie.
I mean he's got an argument that he
probably should get a percentage of the
promotion because the,
what they're selling is conor mcgregor
or selling the ufc,
plus conor mcgregor.
The question is,
how much of that card,
what would it be?
What would the paper.
We don't know what the numbers are,
so let's pretend the number is 2
million,
which would be like the greatest of all
time,
right?
It probably wouldn't hit that.
I don't know.
I bet it's thrown on one seven.
Let's just say 2 million because it's
easy to correct.
So let's say that what percentage bought
It because of connor,
It might be a million 1 million plus for
sure.
It might be 1 million,
1 million,
1 million people might have bought the
paper view specifically because of one
human being.
That is not outrageous to say and.
But this is the other thing in connor's
favorite name,
another star who can do that?
Rhonda can't quite do that.
she can't quite do it.
She and she's talking about this might
be my last fight,
blah blah blah.
So I don't think she said that.
I think she said she's close to you.
Which when you hear that.
Yeah,
thank you.
It's talking about having one foot out.
So let's say she has two fights left,
maybe three,
who knows,
but she's not the same draw as connor.
It's just not.
It's just you look at the number.
She's not the same job,
but if she comes back beats and Amanda
Nunez,
armbars and then fights board and then
fights.
Holly beats beats holly gets a rematch.
Arm barcelona's biggest counter.
You don't know that because as that
happened to mr joe rody.
But here's the thing,
as these people,
when they're star gets more and more
giant as rhonda,
if rhonda came back and started winning
again,
her star would get more and more giant.
It would get bigger with fuel more.
The more bodies she claims,
the more fuel for her fire will have.
That is what happens all the time.
It means pure speculaTion,
but when the way connor has been
winning,
she can win in spectacular fashion or
the way she was winning.
When she fucked up Alexis Davis and sara
mcmann,
merck and girls merck,
and then she custom 1:15
she couldn't ever make,
but you know saying fuck no,
why not?
She's,
she's way too big,
but is she okay?
That'D be,
I mean,
yeah,
beCause she lives really,
really rushed away and sometimes people
that ain't.
That's.
This is nothing.
But um,
if for concert and this,
and again I'm not rooting for favorites,
I'm just saying from business standpoint
for connor,
he's such a big draw,
right?
What's going to help him in this
negotiating power?
If rhonda worked her lose this next
fight because then he's like,
I'm the only motherfucker in town.
You guys were claiming me and rhonda.
That's cool.
She just lost.
I need my fucking money.
Well,
and by the way,
rhonda has a tough fight in front of
her.
Amanda nunez is god damn scary.
She's scary girl.
As I was saying before,
ronda lost a holly.
I was saying she should have got the
title fight and I said,
I said that I think she's the most
dangerous one.
And I was talking shit to you.
The way she stopped sara mcmann,
she cracks with that right hand.
She hits like a truck.
He hits like a dude,
but she.
well,
cyborg hits like a dude.
Amanda hits like a strong girl.
Big difference.
A board like tyrone woodley with let's
be real.
She hits so hard and gets no love
because she's so god damn scary and
can't make the weight.
She also has a a better arsenal like
shelter,
kicks and knees on the ground.
I think amanda,
amanda,
but amanda has lost on the ground before
she got beat up by cats and gone on the
ground.
Correct cyber.
Grip your limbs off,
but she's getting no love but she's too
big.
I know.
It sucks.
They were well and again if they did
that whole thing where I'm talking aBout
they eliminated weight cuts,
so it'd be two girls cyborg with
fighter,
like one 80,
one 80.
It'd be.
It'd be her and that big ass girl.
Gabby gets to 80,
but that's all we got for.
You would have to cut weight to me when
we fight every other weekend,
like tim silvia and andre arlovski.
Let's do that every other weekend or a
fight.
Let them fight like every other weekend
because all we had in the old days.
But uh,
I,
I think for rhonda,
Amanda Nunez,
fight stylists getting can.
We don't know.
We don't know where rhonda is a mental
state.
Is that.
But stylists gates a great matchup for
rhonda?
I think so,
yeah.
I think if she comes ready prepared as a
good camp,
she mercer,
but don't you think that you look at the
way she fucked up me should take eagle.
Like that girl presents a lot of danger
with those punches.
Especially considering what happened
with holly and ronda.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think she presents A lot of danes
shoot 100 percent.
Joe.
I think you're right in that,
but I think her marching forward is the
Perfect antidote to get marked by rhonda
because she's like,
oh,
come get some of this judo armbars if
she marches forward,
which is really all she knows how to do.
You know what I'm saying?
Could it be interesting?
It's a great fight either way,
but it's also interesting to see what
we're rhonda his head is now she's
coming back to the x factor because if
it's wrong,
100 percent,
she beats her.
I think nine out of 10 times strong
words it.
I know,
but if it's rhonda who's kinda,
oh,
I want to do movies,
I don't do this,
this isn't for me.
You're going to get marked because that
girl hit so hard.
Well,
what rhonda has and what you want to
has,
you know,
and not a whole lot of other women have
it is one thing that they do where
they're really fucking good at it and
then they have all those other stuff.
Correct.
Whereas like paige vanzant is kind of
learning the whole sport.
She's learning as she goes,
saying I should go,
but she,
what she does,
what paige has is just toughness and
she's hot.
That nestle,
that helps definitely helps.
but there's not other girls you know,
other than valentina.
Valentina shift chanko.
She's another one that's bad ass.
Who is another super powerful striker.
Yeah.
I mean,
the way she handled holly holm,
standing up.
I know man.
Yeah.
Handled her.
Just countered her.
It will.
That looping left hook,
that hook.
That throws off the right side.
Yeah.
She's another one,
but there's not you.
They need more of those,
you know.
I agree.
That's where mackenzie dern fits.
Exactly.
Can they come and do work and she's
gorgeous.
But I'm saying if,
if conner's like,
listen,
I don't wish bad on anyone,
but if ron were to lose,
we thrown a party in Ireland becaUse I'm
the only show in town now.
Gimme my FuCking piece of the pie.
Well,
nobody has that sort of personality that
he has no one ever.
I think even he eclipses ali.
I've been clips is all of them.
I think he's.
He's bigger than shell sunnen for sure.
As far as like his ability to talk shit.
Not big,
but yeah,
I think he is.
I think he's better than ali baba.
Ali stood for different things.
Right.
His message is more important.
Fight for equal rights was also fighting
to stop the Vietnam war.
At times he had several things for him
that were bigger.
Correct.
Is white privilege is nice suits,
nice suits.
If government is not trying to send them
over to fight in a war zone,
even a,
they're not stripping his belt for how
long?
Three years.
Three prime.
It's just like basically taking the belt
from conrad in three years.
We'll see you soon.
And then it comes back to three years
after not having trained at all.
Ali didn't even work out for three years
because when all he wasn't fighting,
it was like,
why would I work out?
Well,
fucked up.
So.
And he was never the same as he.
No,
no.
He,
not only was he not the same.
He didn't have the footwork anymore.
I didn't have the endurance.
And moi really came back.
You look at his body when he came back
and fought,
he fought.
jerry quarry has come back,
but yes,
smooth.
And that's what's scary.
Not scary,
but to me it's just to see what happens
with jon jones because now they
suspended for a year.
Right.
And he's been out even longer and then
before that,
so they're stupid as title.
And then dana obviously,
you know,
he never sticks to what he says.
Sometimes he does,
but he goes,
I'll never be a main event again.
Like we can't book him at the main event
because we can't trust them anymore.
Wow.
I know.
Right.
So for john,
granted he's doing that,
that flow grappling event against the
fuck out of here.
That flow grappling.
He could have been fighting for the ufc
heavyweight title.
Oh no,
I'm just saying let's see.
Joint something active.
Like at least he's not muhammad ali.
Yeah,
I guess he's lost millions of dollars,
but at least he's doing something in
combat sports.
Well he's only suspended for a year
retroactively.
July.
Second.
Yeah.
So he has to get a while before that.
He did that huge laugh for you.
$200.
So when he comes back it's one inch to
see what we get out of.
I know.
And then he came back and he fought over
in st prue and you know,
look,
kind of tentative.
And then you saw jimmy madame while run
through over in st prue.
All these guys are getting better.
They're getting better.
They're rising up and you know,
rumble rumbles,
fight dc for the title again.
That's gonna be a real interesting
fight.
Super interesting.
Remember,
rumbled did land that huge.
Dc and platinum.
Yeah.
who knows?
In this fight.
He's got neon lance in his corner now.
He's had them for a few years now.
He's worked with a lot on his grappling.
he guarantees concentrated a lot more.
His wrestling.
There's a lot of videos of him running
wrestling drills,
wrestling nonstop.
So he's preparing,
preparing to get up is preparing for
takedown defense fund fight,
man.
It's a toss up for me.
A toss up.
And then jon jones has all this laugh.
Comes back and you'd say rumble for a
reason.
Wins.
He's like,
what's up man?
Yeah,
let's do it.
Well,
why do you think he's going to get a
straight shot at the title?
I don't even know if we would get a
straight shot at the title.
And upon coming back,
you don't know.
Everyone wants to see in it.
Maybe that's why the fans demand,
it might be something going on by by the
time this time rolls around next year or
july rolls around,
so he's gonna.
He's free in july.
Whether that means.
See,
I don't know how suspensions work,
but what I would have been explained to
me is performance enhancing drugs.
Suspensions don't even allow you to
train with other fighters are on the
roster.
Really?
Yes.
When your suspension is up,
then you can train with them.
I don't think you're even supposed to be
sparring with them.
once they hand down a suspension.
That regulation do know about.
That man is done.
Right.
I looked that up,
jamie.
I don't think that's true.
Wrap tHis up soon.
Yeah,
I don't think that's true.
I hope it's not because it's crazy
because you could help your teammates.
Even if you're suspended,
you could still train and help your team
and also sharpen your sword a little
bit.
It's like telling a guy who was an
accountant.
You're suspended for a year.
You can't even touch a calculator when
he's touching calculators.
Yeah,
go.
Does that t three Texas Instruments?
Uh,
no.
They used to make them have them in
school.
Remember those.
Now it's now your phone's spike in
three.
It was like a fucking game boy.
Yeah,
like the calculator business man.
They took a hit.
There are no longer around who's buying
calculus?
They're like blockbuster.
There's none of theM left.
Men's over the same thing.
Jamie,
say anything.
The first article I clicked on was the
one from last year.
So I don't think so.
But the other thing,
to your point where you don't think
he'll.
Who says they'll get a title shot?
The lightweight,
uh,
the light heavyweight division is just
ell dinosaurs besides the top few guys
there are so old.
John's lIke,
I'm not fucking fighting shogun again.
I don't know how dare you fight again.
But jimmy man was a very dangerous fight
for anybody right now.
He's a dangerous fight for john to the
region.
So I'm not matter what lit up over in st
prue you see what happened when he
fought gusman he got cracked.
Yeah.
Do you see what happened when you got
rumble?
He got crack.
He got dealt with upper echelon.
He dealt with,
right.
It's part of the game well over in st.
[inaudible] just went fucking the full
distance with jon jones and a tough
fight with sleepy John Jones and had a
broken arm.
Yeah,
got his arm broken up.
John broke that arm kicks,
right?
Yeah,
but my point is he went the distance and
st louis took them out pretty quick.
I think he's,
I think not st prue rather jiMmy man and
we took them out pretty quick.
I think mountain was super dangerous,
very dangerous,
very dangerous.
First round for john has come back
fight.
I think taking him down and beating him
up on the ground.
Be john's best 100 percent and he's a
trip.
I'm thrown to the ground and some of
them also.
John's different than anybody else in
his length and his ability to use it
doesn't get hit really.
And his wrestling so fucking good.
Yeah.
He's just so scared.
Not scared to go to the ground anybody,
but you look at light.
The light heavyweight division is
hurting the most out of anyone.
I think you could go down the roster
like god,
dog,
we need some new blood in this bitch.
Yeah,
you might be right,
but the the main event in Brazil is ryan
bader reverse little dog little
mugs.
Like I'll fucking do it all.
Do.
I've been fighting for 35 years when his
little night move like a goddamn
tortoise,
but if you want to pay me,
I'll still do it.
He hasn't taken a same amount of
punishment that his brother has,
but he's taken some big law knockouts.
Yeah.
Hope,
hope,
hope everyone's so.
Could you knock them out with a risk?
My god,
you're like clothesline,
don't know.
And Then the rumble one was just
horrendous to suit.
I told you I was in the back of the luck
of a warming up pat cummings.
I'm a motherfucker warmed up,
but basically doing like arm stretches
couldn't hit mitts.
You so stiff.
I was like,
who's he fighting?
Like,
like,
ah,
he can't go out there.
I looked at his coach.
I'm like,
no,
I can't speak spanish,
but no bueno or portuguese.
Sorry.
Yeah,
the,
the.
There was no committee.
I'm like,
you can't go out there,
man.
I want to grab his leg like a three year
old nutland and walk out of the octagon.
I think Brazil is such a huge hotbed for
mma right now.
It's so gigantic that they need
brazilian stars and you know,
for the main event in particular,
they're like,
just don't have a whole lot of options
in the light heavyweight division,
so someone fucking wake up little nug
out of a slumber because he's
recuperating little log or big dog
little dog because they're.
They're waking up as slumber because
little big nugs done right.
He's a little nod.
They woke his ass up and he's like,
yeah,
I'll fly beta.
he's probably asking for another fight,
but outside of him,
what other good light heavyweights from
Brazil that are in the ufc that you
could sell them in a vintner gloria,
but they already fought.
Right.
But glover just got cracked and he
should probably take quite awhile off
after that knockout.
That was a kind of knock out that you
need to like not do nothing.
Lay low.
Yeah.
He got flat lined.
I mean,
so you got that light habit,
you got shogun,
which I don't know what's going on with
sjogren's.
Got to be done.
If he's not done,
he's probably real close to being.
That's what I'm saying.
Like at light heavyweight bro.
Go through in Brazil though.
Even more so like as far as like
brazilian fighters as far as fame.
Meticulous machida got suspended and
suspended for a long fucking time,
isn't he?
Doesn't he have a two year?
I'm not sure.
It's not good.
I don't know if they've decided or not,
but I felt like he got suspended for two
years.
I mean just look at the brazilian
fighters that especially.
You're right.
Light heavyweight machida was going 85
anyway.
he can float between two and five.
I'm just thinking to five guys he could
line up with in Brazil and not a lot.
Not a whole lot.
I mean beta already fought liotta you
could sell that as a rematch because
remember the little knocked him out in
la.
A pad.
yeah,
but he suspended all the.
You're right though.
All the.
Especially there's not a lot of new
blood in Brazil.
We get josie,
they'll get the faces.
Anderson silva is like fell off.
He just lost the business.
And then you got.
Oh,
then he lost a dc.
So he's basically done.
Well.
Thomas on made.
I was looking really good before cody
garbrandt came around,
who he worked on,
he marked them.
Oh,
who's homeboy that?
Tj dillashaw is fighting kits.
Like a fucking match on linux.
Linux.
That's a good fight.
Very good.
Fight.
Linacre.
Or they told tj like,
listen,
we did think you'd be done with cruz.
You're not getting a title shot.
We're going to garment.
here's linacre though.
And if brent winds and tj winds,
it's a big f on both sides.
Right?
Who knows?
So big,
big if especially on the dominick cruz
side,
good luck hitting that guy.
I know.
But if he does land,
he lands the geox.
Everybody.
I'm a fan man.
He's my favorite at that weight class.
I love that.
He's a old school young.
Uh,
one,
uh,
that weight class went 35.
Just that he rUns me oF Chuck ladell.
He's just a small outage.
No doubt.
Good looking dude,
two inches out.
Like it.
I like it.
I like the whole package.
Like the knockout power.
I liked that.
He merck's dudes or we got to wrap this
up.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
Quit dudes in the theater and the kid t
fat k.com.
Brendan.
Shop on twitter and instagram at the
laugh factory.
Thursday son.
Shit,
getting real and stand up again.
How many times have you been on stage
now?
by myself?
Like that?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean we do.
I always start stand up the fight and
the kids,
but a comedy store and I think three
times in this.
The first time it laugh factory shit.
I know,
I get it.
Love it.
All right.
Thursday go out.
What time does it show?
A 8:00
if you're in la.
Represent.
All right.
Thanks brother.
Thank you man.
Fun times.
I miss you.
love you.
Love you too,
man.
See you soon.